في جوله الحصاد معكم جلال شهد طبعا في
الوقت الذي نحدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل
اخرى الاحداث الابرز هي الزلزلين الذين
وقع في هاتاي في تركيا مره اخرى نبدا
جولتنا بصور زلزال جديد ضرب مساء اليوم
مناطق في تركيا وسوريا قوه الزلزال في
احدى المناطق التابعه لانطاكيا
بلغت سته درجات
واربعه اعشار غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا من
المدن التي شملها الزلزال ايضا وقد هرع
الناس فيها الى الشوارع تحسبا لمزيد من
الهزات الارتداديه العنيفه ايضا نتابع صور
ونحن نخبركم انه في ادلب بشمال غربي سوريا
كان للزلزال الجديد وقعوا ايضا
ولما تندمل جروح الزلزال السادس من الشهر
الجاري وسط ضعف في وسائل الانقاذ والاغاثه
في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا ونحن نقول لكم
هذه الصور المباشره من الاماكن التي تضررت
من الزلزلين الجديدين في
ماذا في عناوين اليوم
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
هيئه رصد الكوارث التركيه تعلن وقوع
زلزلين جديدين بقوه
6.4.8 انهيار مباني في مناطق الشمال
السوري والسكان في لبنان وفلسطين والاردن
شعروا بالزلزال
اذا هذه الصور نتابعها الان من
حيث ضرب زلزلان
هذه المنطقه في هاتاي
نتابع هذه الصور حتى الان
لا ضحايا بحسب المعلومات الوارده الحديث
عن اصابات طفيفه
جراء سقوط الحجاره او تدافع او قفز بعض
الاشخاص والناس من المنازل جراء الخوف من
مصير مماثل للزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب كهرما
مراش في السادس من شباط فبراير الجاري اذا
حتى الان هذه الصور التي وردتنا لتهدم بعض
المباني لا سيما في المناطق التركيه طبعا
في سوريا وفي الاردن وفي فلسطين وفي لبنان
شعروا بهذا الزلزال بشكل واضح بحسب
مواردنا حتى الان استمرت هذه الهزات الى
حوالي 18 ثانيه
او عشرين ثانيه اذا افاده افادت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه ان زلزلين بقوه
سته فاصله اربعه وخمسه فاصله اثنان على
مقياس ريختر ضرب مركز منطقه دفنه وداق في
ولايه هاتاي جنوبيه البلاد مساء اليوم
اداره الكوارث اضافت ان سكان مدن هاتاي
وغازي عنتاب ومرسين واضنه وانطاليا وكرمان
مراش شعروا بالزلزال وشهد مواطنوا مدن عده
ينزلون للشوارع خوفا من تضرر المباني من
اثار الزلزلين وقد شعر سكان الشمال السوري
ولبنان والاردن وفلسطين كما اسلفت
بالزلزلين فيها تاي بتركيا
كان مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج يستعد للظهور
على الهواء من مدينه انطاكيا وقع الزلزال
الجديد حيث وثقت كاميرا الجزيره اللحظات
الاولى وهلع السكان في احد المخيمات
انطاكيا حيث يقطن منكبو الزلزلين
الان وقع زلزال استمر لثوان
يا الله
اذا كنا قلنا انه لا ضحايا ولكن بخبر عاجل
وزير الداخليه التركي يعلنوا وفاه ثلاثه
اشخاص واصابه مئتين 213 عقب زلزلين
الجديدين اللذين ضربا هاتاي في جنوب تركيا
وقد نشرت هيئه المسح الجيولوجيه الامريكيه
صوره تظهر مركز الزلزال في ولايه هاتاي
جنوبيه تركيا وقالت انه ضرب المنطقه على
عمق عشره كيلو مترات عند الساعه الثامنه
واربع دقائق بتوقيت المحلي في تركيا
اذا اذكر بانه بحسب وزير الداخليه التركيه
اعلن وفاه ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه مئتين
وثلاثه عشر عقب الزلزلين الجديدين الذين
ضرب هاتاي في جنوب تركيا فؤاد اقطاي نائب
الرئيس التركي حث المواطنين على عدم
التوجه الى المباني المتضرره نستمع الى ما
قاله فادقتها
نرجو ونتمنى من جميع مواطنين عدم التوجه
اود الدخول الى المباني بغض النظر عن نسبه
خطورتها عدم الذهاب لاخراج الامتعه او
الحاجات نرجو ونتمنى
يفكروا في صحتكم في عائلتكم في اولادكم في
ازواجكم في زوجاتكم نرجو عدم الدخول
والتوجه الى تلك المباني بعون الله نحن
سنقوم بتعويضكم بجميع الاموال والحاجات
ولكن لا نستطيع ان نقوم بارجاع نفس واحده
خسرناها جميع الوزارات والمديريات
والمدراء والفرق موجودون في الساحه
يتابعون جميع المواضيع والمستجدات عن كثب
اذا تاثير الزلزلين لم يقتصر على تركيا في
شمال سوريا افاده دفاع المدني السوري
باصابه عدد من المدنيين بجروح متفاوته
جراء زلزلي هاتاي واضاف ان اغلب الاصابات
وقعت بسبب سقوط حجاره او القفص من الابنيه
المرتفعه والتدافع وانهيار بنائين متصدعين
غير ماهولين وبئذنه مسجد في جنديرس شمالي
حلب وعدد من الابنيه المتصدعه في خربه
الجوز والحمزيه والمالاند والزوف وبيت
صوفان غربي ادلب دون اصابات فيها كما
انهارت جدران وشرف منازل في عده مدن
وبلدات في ريف حلب وادلب اذن
الاضرار لم تقتصر على تركيا ولكن كما
ذكرنا ايضا في لبنان وفي فلسطين وفي
الاردن شعروا بهذه الهزات معنى من مركز
الزلزال دفنه بولايه هاتاي التركيه مراسل
جزيره عمر الحاج من غازي عنتاب ينضم الينا
ايضا المعتز بلا حسن ومن ريف ادلب مراسل
جزيره صهيب الخلف ومن ريف حلب مراسل جزيره
عامر حلبي اذا عمر الحاج ابدا معك الاعلان
عن ثلاثه وفيات واكثر من 200
اصابه جراء زلزلين فيها اطلعنا على اخر
المعلومات والتطورات الوارده
صحيح جلال هذا ما اعلنه وزير الداخليه
سليمان سولو الذي عاد مباشره بعد وقوع
الزلزال من مدينه كهرمان مرعش الى هاتاي
من مركزي الطوارئ اداره الطوارئ هنا في
انطاكيا اعلن عن عدد القتلى الان هناك صور
لعمال الانقاذ ينادون على عالقنا تحت
الانقاض في احد الاحياء هنا في مدينه دفنه
نحاول الوصول الى هناك ولكن الطرق مقطوعه
في طريقي الى هنا من هاتاي الى هذه
المدينه هناك لعشرات من الابنيه وفقا
للشهادات عمال الانقاذ اضافه الى سكان
المحلين كلها سقطت خلال الزلزال الذي كان
مصدره هنا كان مركزه هنا مدينه ادفنه رئيس
البلديه رئيس بلديه دفنه اضافه الى رئيس
بلديه هاتاي تحدث عن وجود مثل هذه الحالات
عنقين تحت الانقاذ وان كانت فرق الانقاذ
تقول هنا انها استجابت لكل هذه النداءات
وانها
حركت فرقها اتجاه هذه المناطق التي اشير
الى احتمال وجود عالقين فيها ولكن مره
اخرى هناك صور الان يتناقلها الاعلام
التركي عن عالقين تحت الانقاض وان الفرق
تعمل على استخراجهم من هناك
بشكل متتالي جلال كما ذكرت عند الساعه
الثامنه واربع دقائق المركز الزلزال الاول
كان هنا دفنا اضافه الى مدينه التي ايضا
هناك مناشدات لوصول لاستجابه فرق الانقاذ
او دعوه فرق الانقاذ الاستجابه الى حالات
هناك ربما لعالقين تحت الانقاض السلطات
حذرت بشكل حاسم المواطنين من العوده الى
الابنيه بشكل عام وخاصه منها التي وسمت
انها متضرره بشكل متوسط او فيها اضرار
كبيره وان هذه الحالات كلها لهؤلاء الذين
عادوا الى هذه الابنيه بالرغم من
التحذيرات اضافه الى الضرر الذي اصاب بعض
الماره خلال وقوع الزلزال فرق الانقاذ
مستنفره هنا
الدفاع المدني في شمال سوريا افاد قبل
قليل بان 130 مصابا في حصيله غير نهائيه
بعد زلزلين فيها تاي اطلعنا على التطورات
والمعلومات حيث انت
بالفعل جلال الاصابات هنا معظمها من سقوط
حجاره على على المدنيين في الشارع ونتيجه
كذلك انهيار جدران منازل او شرف منازل على
في الشارع وبالتالي على المدنيين لكن
هنالك اصابات اخرى نتيجه حالات من الهلع
والخوف نتيجه ان اناسا رموا بانفسهم من
الابنيه السكنيه من شروفات منازلهم ما
تعرضوا الى كسور وبالاضافه الى حالاتنا
الاغماء
فهذا العدد من الجرحى معظمهم نتيجه حالات
كسور ونتيجه حالات اغماء وصلت الى
المستشفيات وفقت دفاع المدني فان هنالك
130 جريحا معظمهم كسور وحالات اغماء
بالاضافه الى جرحى سقطت عليهم حجاره جدران
شرف منازل هذا في مناطق شمال الغربي سوريا
النظام السوري كذلك وسائل الاعلام النظام
السوري تتحدث ان هنالك 120 حاله اصابه نفس
الحالات تماما نتيجه حالات الهلع والخوف
واناس رموا بانفسهم من الابنيه السكنيه
الدفاع المدني يؤكد بان هنالك ابنيه سكنيه
قد انهارت في جنديرس وفي مناطق اخرى في
ريف حلب لكن يقول انه لا اصابات او لا
حالات وفيات حتى الان نتيجه ان هذه
الابنيه التي انهارت في جنديرس هي ابنيه
لم يكن فيها سكان جنديرس 85 في المئه من
مبانيها بالاصل كانت مدمره اما بشكل كامل
او بشكل جزئي الابنيه الباقيه ايله للسقوط
بالتالي المدينه بنسبه كبيره جدا كانت قد
نزح السكان منها هذا ما يفسر انه ليس
هنالك اصابات نتيجه انهيار المباني
السكنيه في جنديرس لكن الان المشهد
الرئيسي هو حاله الهلع هو الخوف الكبير
لدى السكان حاله نزوح جماعيه من المدن
باتجاه
مخيمات باتجاه
قوارع او قاريعات الطرق الى حافتي الطرق
في شمال غربي سوريا خوفا من الهزات
الارتداديه التي نشعر بها هنا ايضا ما بين
الفينه والاخرى نتحدث عن اكبر هزه حصلت
بعد الزلزلين الاوليين في سته شباط الان
هذين الزلزلين اللذين حصل قبل قليل هما
الاكبر على مدى الايام الماضيه فبالتالي
الناس عندها حاله كبيره من الهلع وموجودون
في مخيمات في حدائق عامه في ساحات من يملك
سياره فهو في سيارته وسط تحذيرات من
الدفاع المدني ان لا يعود الناس الى الاب
الى مبانيهم خصوصا التي تلك التي هي قد
اصابها تصدعات وتشققات
كما اسلفنا اعلن الدفاع المدني في شمال
سوريا عن سقوط مئه وثلاثين مصابا صهيب
الخلف في ريف ادلب في ريف ادلب عفوا ماذا
وصلكم من معلومات
صهيب مع الاسف فقدنا الاتصال مع صهيب
المعتز بالله حسن متواجد في غازي عنتاب ما
التطورات لديك المعتز بالله
جلال نحن هنا في غازي عنتاب شعرنا بقوه
هذا الزلزال التي بلغت 6.4 وشعرنا بالهزه
التي تلتها اكثر من خمس درجات هناك كان
هناك في بعد زلزال مباشره كان هناك العديد
من الهزات الارتداديه كان هناك قلق لدى
الناس في مدينه غازي عنتاب خرج الكثير
منهم الى الشوارع خشيه حدوث مزيدا من
الهزات الوضع الان في غازي عنتاب نستطيع
القول انه اهدا قليلا مازال هناك اشخاص
ينتظرون في الشارع لا يستطيعون لا يريدون
الدخول الى بيوتهم خشيه حدوث هزات اخرى
كثير من الاشخاص هم يبقون في سياراتهم كان
هناك ربما تزود بالوقود لكثير من السيارات
من اجل الانتظار في هذه السيارات ليلا لكن
ولي غازي عنتاب او محافظ بالله فقط انوه
قائلا ساعود اليك المعهد القومي للبحوث
الفلكيه في مصر يعلن عن هزه ارضيه بقوه
6.4 درجات شمال رفح سنحاول ايضا ان نستفسر
عن هذا الموضوع في شمال رفح بحسب المعهد
القومي للبحوث الفلكيه في مصر هزه ارضيه
بقوه 6.4 درجات شمال رفح سنحاول ان نستفسر
عن هذا الموضوع في رفح اعود اليك مره
جديده المعتز بالله حسن
لدينا على شاشه الجزيره قبل ساعه من الان
تقريبا احد خبراء خبراء الجيولوجيون وقد
تحدث عن ان هناك احتماليه لمزيد من الهزات
وخصوصا باتجاه الجنوب لكن هنا في غازي
عنتاب الوضع نستطيع القول انه حاليا مستقر
مازال هناك اشخاص في الشوارع واشخاص
ينتظرون في سيارتهم كان هناك العديد من
الاشخاص الذين حاولوا التزود بالوقود من
اجل البقاء في سياراتهم ليلا لكن محافظ
مدينه غازي عنتاب نشر على تويتر تغريده
قال فيها ان سكان مدينه غازي عنتاب شعروا
بهذه العزه ولكن لا يوجد في لم يسجل في
مدينه غازي عنتاب اي اضرار سوى سقوط جزئي
او سقوط جزء من بناء مهجور في المدينه وقد
طالب محافظ مدينه غازي عنتاب السكان
بالابتعاد عن المباني التي شهدت تضررا
جراء الزلزلين الذين ضرباء تركيا في
السادس من شباط الحالي وهذه الاجراءات
بحسب السلطات الرسميه هنا هنا ضروريه
خصوصا جلال انه كان هناك في الفتره
الماضيه احصاء لكثير من الابنيه التي
تضررت بالزلزال وقامت اداره الطوارئ
والكوارث التركيه وفرقها العامله على
تصنيف هذه المباني الى عده درجات
ايل السقوط او متوسطه الخطر او قليله
الخطر وقد
نصح الناس بالابتعاد عن المباني الاله
للسقوط التي هناك احتمال لسقوطها مع هذه
الهزات وهذا هو ربما جلال سبب خوف الناس
من ان يكون هناك هزات اشد قد تؤدي الى بعض
الاضرار في المدينه لكن بحسب محافظ غازي
عنتاب لا يوجد اضرار سوى جزء من مبنى
مهجور وطالب الناس بالابتعاد عن المباني
المتضرره بانتظار ان استطيع ان اتواصل مع
صهيب الخلف في ريف ادلب لنسال عن الوضع
هناك نشير فقط الى ان الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا في السادس من شباط بلغت قوته
سبعه فاصل سبعه درجات او اعشار الدرجه على
مقياس ريختر بينما الزلزال الاخير الذي
وقع قبل ساعات في هاتاي بلغ سته فاصل
اربعه وخمسه فاصله ثمانيه على مقياس
ريخترف فيه مركزين مختلفين في منطقه
سمنداغ وفي منطقه دفنه لا ادري اذا كان
صهيب تسمعني صهيب
نعم نعم نريد ان نسال عن الوضع لديكم في
في حيث انت خصوصا مع الاعلان عن 130 مصابا
جراء هذا هذين الزلزلين
نعم عشرات العائلات ما زالوا في سياراتهم
او ما زالوا في الساحات العامه في مدينه
ادلب بعد الزلزال يتخوفون من العوده الى
بيوتهم ويتخوفون من تجدد الهزات الارضيه
ويمكن للزميل المصور ان يوجه الكاميرا نحو
السيارات التي ما تزال تقف حتى اللحظه في
وسط الشارع وكذلك على امتداد الشارع
والناس الذين يتواجدون في الحديقه العامه
هذا المشهد حقيقه يذكرنا بالليله الاولى
والثانيه بعد الزلزال عندها كان الناس
يخافون من العوده الى بيوتهم وهذا ما حصل
اليوم ايضا بعد الزلزال والاهتزاز العنيف
للارض الذي حصل وعند دخول حقيقه الى مدينه
ادلب بعد الزلزال كان كانت مشاهداتي صادمه
حقيقه لحجم الناس الذين يمشون في الشوارع
باتجاه المزارع القريبه من مدينه اد عند
مداخل مدينه ادلب والسيارات التي
تصطفوا في طوابير باتجاه خارج المدينه
الناس هنا صاروا يخافون بشكل كبير من حدوث
الزلازل الدفاع المدني السوري قال ان عدد
الاصابات قد ارتفع فعلا الى 130 شخص وكل
الذين اصيبوا اصيبوا بسبب
بسبب السقوط الاحجار عليهم او بسبب
التدافع بعد الزلزال لانهم ارادوا ان
يخرجوا بسرعه الى خارج بيوتهم
الاستجابه الطارئه قالت ان الاصابات كانت
خفيفه وان جميع من اصيب بسبب الزلزالين
خرج من المستشفى وان اوضاع من اصيبوا فعلا
كانت اصاباتهم خفيفه لكن هناك عدد من
الابنيه دمر بسبب او بعد الزلزال هذه
الابنيه كانت قد تعرضت
[موسيقى]
تصدعات كبيره بعد الزلزال السابق وهذه
الابنيه كانت في القرى الملاصقه للشريط
الحدودي مع تركيا نتحدث عن خربه الجوز وعن
الملاند وكذلك بيت صوفان
والحمزيه كل هذه القرى في منطقه ريف سلقين
وهذه المنطقه بطبيعه الحال كانت قد تعرضت
لاضرار كبيره في الزلزال السابق ودمر
الكثير من البيوت فيها وايضا سكانها ما
زالوا يعيشون في اول الكثير من سكانها ما
زالوا يعيشون في مراكز ايواء منتشره بجانب
تلك القرى والبلدات حجم التشرد الذي يحصل
الان حقيقه يزيد الضغوطات على المنظمات
الانسانيه التي كانت تسعى الى تزويد
النازحين الذين نزحوا بعد الزلزال الذين
تقدرهم منظمات محليه باكثر من 100 الف شخص
كانت المنظمات الانسانيه تريد ان تزودهم
بخيم مستقله لكل عائله حتى يتجنب العيش في
مراكز ايواء جماعيه لكن حقيقه التشرد الذي
حصل اليوم
يزيد الاعباء على هذه المنظمات الانسانيه
البيوت التي تصدعت يصل عددها بحسب احصاءات
منظمات محليه الى اكثر من عشره الاف بيت
وهذه المباني تنتظر لجان مختصه حتى تقوم
بالكشف عليها لتقييم الاضرار وحتى تقييم
الاضرار فان سكان هذه البيوت ما زالوا
يعيشون في الخيام وما زالوا يعيشون في
مراكز ايواء وهم لا يتجراون على العوده
اليها ويخافون من سقوطها وكما حدث اليوم
حقيقه بعد الزلزال اذ سقطت الكثير من
المباني كما اسلفنا سنعود اليك بطبيعه
الحال لمن انضم الينا الان في هذه التغطيه
وقع زلزلان جديده في منطقه هاتاي في جنوب
تركيا بقوه 6.4 وخمسه فاصل ثمانيه على
مقياس في منطقه سي دفنه
مساء النور بعد الزلزالين الكبيرين قبل
اسبوعين تاثر اهل المنطقه من الجديد
بزلزالين الجديدين
كما فضلت ثلاثه وفاه
و20013 جرحه حتى الان وهناك لا شك الخوف
من ازداد قد يزداد العدد على اكثر
بسبب قطع الكهرباء وعدم الوصول الى كل
الانقاذ الذي هدم اخيرا بعد الزلزال
الاخير
لكن
البيانات الرسميه بعد الاخبارات يمكن 30
اقبال من عده اماكن
اكدوا ان
الذي تضرر من الزل الاخير ثلاثه وفاه و23
جرحى
الذي هدم جزئيا قبل اسبوعين هدم من الجديد
ورجال البحث والانقاذ هم يبحثون عن البيوت
اذا
رجع واحد الى هذه البيوت او كان يعيشان
بعض الناس في داخل البيوت يحب يعني يحاول
ان يتاكدوا
اذا كان الناس يعني احياء في البيوت
مهدومه جزئيا
ولكن بالمقارنه الى
الزلزالين القديمين قبل اسبوع
هناك امكانيه اكثر لان
رجال الطواري رجال بحثه والانقاذ مؤسسات
الحكوميه مؤسسات
غير حكوميه وان كانوا متواجدين في اماكن
الزلزال الزلزال صحيح كان مركزها مدينه
احطها ولكن تاثر المدن اخرى الذي حصل
الزلزال قبل اسبوعين بالاضافه الى خارج
تركيا مثل لبنان سوريا وحتى فلسطين ستبقى
معنا سيد عزت في اسطنبول نشرك معنا في هذه
التغطيه من شمال ادلب السيد منير مصطفى
نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوري سيد منير
كيف تصف لنا الاصابات في الشمال السوري
وبلغت 130 بحسب الدفاع المدني
نعم في الحقيقه يعني تجاوز عدد الاصابات
130 ممكن حتى
133 تقريبا في هذه اللحظه الحمد لله هذه
الاصابات تصنف بين الاصابات الخفيفه
والاصابات المتوسطه
الانهيارات كانت في الابنيه المتصدعه هي
بالاساس من منذ يعني الزلزال الماضي وهذه
الابنيه في الغالب هي ابنيه مفرغه بشكل
كامل اما الاصابات فهي حصلت جراء التدافع
اثناء الخروج الى خارج المباني وجراء
تساقط بعض الحجاره من المباني ادت الى بعض
الاصابات الخفيفه وهناك جزء من هذه
الاصابات هي حالات اغماء جراء الهلع
والخوف الشديد الذي اصاب المدنيين اثناء
وقوع هذا الزلزال حتى هذه اللحظه لم تسجل
اي حاله وفاه لم يسجل اي منطقه فيها
عالقين تحت الانقاض الابنيه التي تعرضت
للانهيار في هذه الهزه هي ابنيه بالاساس
هي متصدعه وهي خاليه بشكل كامل من السكان
نسال الله ان السلامه لجميع السكان في
شمال غرب سوريا او جنوب تركيا وفي كل
المناطق التي تاثر تاثرت في هذا الزلزال
لا يوجد يعني اي تسجيل الحمد لله لاي حتى
حالات اصابات خطيره الاصابات كلها تصنف
بين الخفيفه والمتوسطه ولكن يعني اصابات
جديده 130 اصابه كما نقل لنا
مراسلنا قبل قليل صهيب الخلف وحتى عمر
حلبي الناس في حاله خوف يرفضون العوده الى
بيوتهم يبيتون اما في خيام متوفره او حتى
في السيارات ملعب بالاضافه الذي يزيده هذا
عليكم
نعم في الحقيقه يعني منذ وقوع الزلزال
الماضي المدنيين هم في حاله خوف شديد هناك
العديد من الهزات الارتداديه التي كانت
تحصل حتى تاريخ هذه حتى تاريخ اليوم ومنذ
اكثر من ساعه يعني هذا يصنف الى زلزال
وليس هو هزاع ارتديه طبعا هذا الزلزال زاد
من حاله الخوف والهلع وزاد من خروج
المدنيين باتجاه الطرقات طبعا المدنيين
حتى هذه اللحظه هم متواجدون في الطرقات
والشوارع طبعا لا يعودون الى المنازل طبعا
ونحن ننصح ايضا بتواجدهم باماكن بعيده عن
عن هذه المباني طبعا بسبب ان الهزات
الاعتداديه ممكن ان تحصل في هذه الساعات
القادمه طبعا هذه اخذناها من الزلزال
القديم كان هناك هزات عديده بعد هذا
الزلزال ونحن نخشى من هذه المباني التي
تعرضت لهزه قويه في السادس من هذا الشهر
والان تتعرض الى هزه اخرى وهذا يزيد من
تصدع بشكل اكبر ويزيد من فتره من فرصه
انهيار هذه الابنيه الدفاع الذي ينصح جميع
المدنيين ان يكونوا متواجدين في العراء
طبعا للاسف المساعدات التي وصلت الى شمال
غرب سوريا لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه هي
مساعدات خجوله لم تكفي المتشردين باثر
الزلزال القديم والان يزيد اكثر بسبب يعني
خروج باقي السكان الى الشوارع او الى
الاماكن المفتوحه مما يزيد الحاجه والطلب
الى الاماكن الامنه التي هي قد يلتجا
اليها الناس في مثل هذه اللحظات الكارثيه
طبعا فرق الخوذ بيضاء الدفاع الذي هي اصلا
متواجده ضمن مناطق العمل لم تعد الى
مراكزها هم في حاله استنفار كامل هم الان
يعني من وقوع هذا الزلزال انطلقوا باتجاه
باتجاه عمليات
التفتيش المباني الايه السقوط وتفتيش كل
المناطق حتى يستطيعون
الوصول لمن يحتاج الى المساعده وينقذون
ويسعفون من يحتاج الى عمليات الاسعاف تبقى
معنا سيد منير اعود الى السيد عزت شاهين
اذن كما قال وزير الداخليه وفاه ثلاثه
اشخاص واصابه
213 هل لديكم فكره عن طبيعه هذه الاصابات
الجديده جراء الزلزلين الجديدين في هاتاي
المعلومات الذي حصلنا من الميدان
انتقلوا الى المستشفيات فقد صار هناك
مشكله في مستشفى
الاسكندرون مستشفى الحكوميه في اسكندرون
وقاموا باخلاء
المرضى من المستشفى الى مستشفيات اخرى
تسعه مستشفيات اخرى
وليس هناك خبر جديد او يعني يصاب كبير في
من
مئه مئتين ثلاثه اشهر شخص الذي انتقل الى
المستشفيات
وطبعا نحن كما فضل الزميلنا في سوريا ننصح
المواطنين في هذه المناطق يعود الى بيوتهم
او الاماكن هناك مباني
وهناك بيانات من الحكومه ومجتمع المدني
لتوفير الخيم في خارج مراكز المدن
وكذلك كثير منهم سيبيتون في داخل سيارات
الذي ما عندهم امكانيات
الخيام هذه الليله
صحيح البرد موجود هناك ولكن
البرد يمكن اخف من الخوف في داخل البيوت
ولو ما يسمى
صالحه للسكن
وبسبب
الزلزال المستمر
ننصح دائما ان يبقىوا بعيدا عن المباني
وكذلك مراكز المدينه
تم تاكيد وجود اشخاص
عالقين تحت الانقاض حتى الان جرى الزلزلين
جديدين
اربعه توفي ثلاثه
واخرجوا واحد
وما سمعنا جديد بالاضافه الى اربعه الذي
ذكر وزير الداخلي
سليمان سيلو قبله يمكن عشر دقائق اذا حتى
الان هناك شخص واحد
تحت الانقاد
تقول انه انت شالوه حيا
اي نعم كان اربعه اربعه تحت الانقاذ خرج
واحد اخرج وحيد حيا
وتوفي ثلاثه في تحت الانقاذ
وهذا هذا الخبر
بالتاكيد من قبل الوزير ولم نسمع الجديد
اذا بقي واحده اخر كذلك ان تعطي الانقاض
في البيوت المهدومه مع زلزال الاخير طيب
السيد منير مصطفى في في شمال سوريا طبعا
منظمات دوليه او المتحده سارعت للقول
بانها مستعده لارسال مزيد من المساعدات
جراء الزلزلين في في هاتاي هل هناك تواصل
مباشر بينكم وبين الامم المتحده لوصول
مساعدات اضافيه
لمن موجودون في العراء الان
نعم في الحقيقه هناك ثلاث معابر تصل بين
شمال غرب سوريا وتركيا وهذه المعابر
الثلاثه هي جاهزه لاستقبال المساعدات ولكن
نحن يعني نطالب الامم المتحده وكافه الدول
التي هي ابدت استعدادها لارسال المساعدات
للاسراع بارسال هذه المساعدات من اجل
تخفيف المعاناه للاسف هذا الزلزال زاد
المعاناه اكثر اكثر للمدنيين هناك ابنيه
ايضا للاسف طالها بعض الشقوق والتصدعات
وهي لم تعد يعني يعني قابله لعوده
المدنيين فزادت الحاجه حقيقه للمدنيه من
اجل عمليات اللواء وللاسف البنيه بنيه
النظام الصحي والمشافي هي بالاساس متعرضه
يعني
لزلزال منذ 15 يوما وهي كانت بادنى يعني
بادنى مقومات
العمل وبعد الزلزال كان هناك يعني شبه
انهيار صحي وهذا الزلزال سيزيد هذه
الاعباء بسبب الاصابات الجديده التي هي
بدات تنتقل الى المشافي وهي تحتاج الى
تلقي العلاج فهذه المساعدات يجب ان يكون
هناك اسراع اكثر لوصول هذه المساعدات الى
مناطق شمالي غرب سوريا من اجل دعم القطاع
الصحي ومن اجل دعم المتضررين من الزلزال
وفراق الدفاع المدني او الفوز البيضاء
التي تعمل على فتح الطرقات وازاله الانقاض
والتعامل مع يعني اي هزه ارتداديه او مع
اي يعني حاله من المباني الايه للسقوط
تحاول يعني يعني التخلص من هذه المبنيه
حتى لا تكون هي يعني مصدر للخطر للمدنيين
المتواجدين في شمال غرب سوريا فنحن نطالب
صراحه الامم المتحده بالاسراع بدخول هذه
المساعدات ويعني عدم التنكر بها لانها
ستخفف من يعني اثار التي تعرض لها
المدنيين جراء ستبقى معنا السيد منير
مصطفى وايضا السيد عزت شاهين اعود مره
جديده الى مواسرينا الخلف المتواجد في ريف
ادلب وفي غازي عنتاب المعتز بلا حسن
اتابعكما وانتم تحاولون جمع معلومات اكثر
ربما على الهواتف هل من جديد المعتز بالله
الوضع في غازي عنتاب جلال على ما هو هناك
فقط في بعض المناطق في المدينه
تواجد للاشخاص في الحدائق مازال هناك حاله
من القلق وخوف من العوده الى المنازل
خصوصا وان
مدينه غازي عنتاب او محافظ مدينه غازي
عنتاب طالب السكان بالابتعاد عن المنازل
او المباني
المتضرره مدينه غازي عنتاب كانت تضررت
بشكل كبير في الزلزلين الماضيين دعنا نذكر
ان مدينه نورداغ التابعه لمحافظه غازي
عنتاب دمرت بشكل كامل وهي اتخذ قرار فعلي
بهدمها
وهناك اخبار عن العمل على نقلها وبناء
بيوت جديده في هذه المدينه اذا هي حاله من
القلق جلال جراء ما حدث نحن شعرنا في
مدينه غازي عنتاب بهذا الزلزال بشكل كبير
وواضح واللا فت ان الهزه لم تكن هزه
اعتياديه بل كانت هزه طويله وبالتالي هذه
هذا الاهتزاز الطويل هو ما تسبب بوجود قلق
لدى الناس وخروج كثير منهم الى الشوارع
عقبه هذا الزلزال حوالي 20 ثانيه بين 18
و20 ثانيه اذا المعتز بالله لا اصابات في
غازي عنتاب صحيح حتى الساعه طبعا
لم يسجل في غازي عنتاب على الاقل بحسب
السلطات الرسميه حتى الان اي اصابه كل ما
في الامر هو ما اعلنه المحافظ من ان
اجزاء من مبنى مهجور
سقطت وطالب الناس الابتعاد عن المباني هذه
هي الحصيله في غازي عنتاب لكن هناك جلال
حاله من القلق وهذه الحاله من القلق
مفهومه خصوصا وان مدينه غازي عنتاب اهتزت
بشكل واضح وايضا هي تتذكر ما حدث في
السادس من شباط الزلزلين الكبيرين الذين
ضرباء المنطقه وكان هناك اضرار وخصوصا في
بعض مناطق
محافظه غازي عنتاب صحيح ايضا القلق واضح
في خلفيه صهيب الخلف
المتواجد بريف ادلب صهيب قربنا اكثر من
هذا الخوف لدى الناس
والذكريات التي ما زالت حاضره جراء
الزلزال الاول الذي بلغت قوته 7. 7 في
كهرمان مراش وتاثيراته في ريف ادلب
نعم قبل قليل اعلنت مديريه التربيه
التابعه للمعارضه بان يوم غد سوف يكون يوم
عطله وسوف تمتد العطله الى يوم السبت
القادم كانت المدارس قد استانفت دوامها
اليوم لكن ومع وجود كثير من المدارس تضررت
بسبب الزلزال والتي بلغ عددها 150 مدرسه
بحسب منسقوا الاستجابه فان مديريه التربيه
التابعه المعارضه عادت الى استئناف العطله
بعد الزلزال اليوم حقيقه ذلك ايضا يصب في
خانه المخاوف الكثير من تجدد الهزات
الارضيه لان الناس بطبيعه الحال يخافون
على ابنائهم من ارسالهم الى المدرسه كذلك
ان الخوف الذي رايناه قبل قليل في مدينه
ادلب حقيقه كان المشهد ماساوي كثيرا لان
الناس كانوا في الشوارع مشيا على اقدامهم
يحاولون الخروج من مدخل مدينه ادلب باتجاه
الاراضي الزراعيه وقد خرجوا فعلا باتجاه
مزارع في الاراضي الزراعيه المحيطه في
ادلب او في السيارات وحتى اللحظه هناك
الكثير من السيارات ما تزال في شوارع
مدينه ادلب ويمكن للزميل المصور ان يحرك
الكاميرا وان تظهر هذه السيارات التي
ما تزال تتوقف في منتصف الطريق وفي على
امتداد الطريق وايضا في الساحات العامه
وكذلك بعض الحدائق ما يزال حتى الان يشهد
وجود من
سكان المدينه وطبعا بسبب درجات الحراره
المنخفضه يعني الناس يلتفون باغطيه سميكه
في محاوله لتامين الدفء لكن العوده الى
المنايا المنازل ثمه
حيالها تخوفات كبيره لانه بطبيعه الحال
الز السابق صدع الكثير من المدن المنسق
والاستجابه تقول ان اكثر من عشره الاف بيت
تصدع بنسب متفاوته وهذه تصدعات قد تكون
كبيره وقد تكون قليله ولكن الدفاع المدني
السوري دائما ما يطالب الناس بعدم العوده
الى البيوت وبانتظار تقييم الاضرار في هذه
البيوت التي تصدعت لذلك فان الكثير من
الناس ممن تصدعت بيوتهم هم حقيقه يفضلون
اللجوء الى مراكز ايواء مؤقته او يحاولون
الحصول على خيمه من المنظمات الانسانيه
وهذا ما يزيد الضغط بشكل كبير على عمال
الاغاثه وعلى موظفي المنظمات الانسانيه
الذين ما زالوا يتلقون المساعدات المحليه
او تلك المساعدات التي تاتي عبر معبر باب
الهوى من الامم المتحده والتي حتى الان
بحسب منظمات محليه لا تفيد الغرض ولا تلبي
جميع احتياجات السكان لذلك فان الكثير من
الناس ما زالوا يعيشون في مرا
مؤقته هذه المراكز وتتميز بان بان الناس
يعيشون فيها بشكل جماعي معزول النساء عن
الرجال
وبسبب كونها بيوت كبيره وخيم ضخمه فان
تامين الدفئ صعب فيها لذلك فان حقيقه
الناس ما زالوا يعيشون يعني اوضاع صعبه
جدا فيما يخص التشرد بسبب تجدد الزلزال
اليكم زلزالين جديدين ساعود اليكم صهيب في
ريف ادلب والمعتز بالله في غازي عنتاب
نعود مره جديده للسيدين منير مصطفى في
شمال سوريا والسيد عزت شاهين في تركيا
لاسالك سيد منير مصطفى كان يتحدث عن صهيب
عن مراكز الايواء المؤقته المتواجده الان
والتي يعني يلجا اليها
المنكوبون كيف تصفونها في ظل الجدل الذي
ما زال قائما حول
المساعدات التي دخلت من المعابر الثلاثه
الى شمال غرب سوريا
في الحقيقه هي مراكز لم تكن كافيه
للمضطرين جراء زلزال الذي حصل في تاريخ
سته الشهر الجاري وهذه المراكز للاسف هي
كانت عرضه لقدوم اشخاص اضافيين يعني اليوم
الشخص الذي كان يملك خيمه ضمن هذه المراكز
او مكان
اضطره لان يستقبل اكثر من عائلتين او ثلاث
عوائل جراء وقوع هذا الزلزال الجديد مما
زاد من من الاقتظاظ ضمن هذه المراكز وزاد
من عدم توفر يعني فرص لاي عائله قد تكون
يعني لها الفرصه ان تدخل الى مثل هذه
المراكز فلذلك يعني نحن كما يعني تحدثت
منذ قليل يعني نطالب بالاسراع في ادخال
هذه المساعدات وبصول هذه المساعدات وتجاوز
العقبات والروتين الذي يحصل يعني في الوقت
يعني الامم المتحده وفي بعض الدول وهذه
يعني المساعدات هي ستكون يعني قد خففت جزء
من التي تحصل في
للمدنيين جراء وقوع هذا الزلزال في
الحقيقه يعني زادت المعاناه اكثر زاد
الطلب على هذه المساعدات بشكل اكبر فلذلك
يعني يجب ان يكون هناك وصول لهذه
المساعدات بشكل اسرع حتى نستطيع ان نتجاوز
هذه
المتطلبات التي بدات تزيد يعني يعني شيئا
فشيئا جراح حدوث هذا الزلزال والهزات
الارتي
طيب نتابع هذه الصور المباشره من هاتاي
هذه الصور لعمال انقاذ لا ندري فعليا ما
الذي يقومون به ولكن نشاهد نشاطا انقاذيا
في امام هذا المبنى والدخان الابيض يرتفع
من هذا المبنى نذكر بان هذا جراء الزلزلين
الجديدين اللذين ضرب ولايه هاتاي بقوه 6.4
وخمسه فاصله ثمانيه تحديدا في منطقتي دفنه
وسمنداغ بولايه هاتاي جنوبيه البلاد الذي
ضربها مساء اليوم اذا متابع هذه الصور
المباشره من هاتاي ونعود ونذكر بان وزير
الداخليه التركي اعلن عن وفاه ثلاثه اشخاص
واصابه
213 عاقبه الزلزلين الجديدين اللذين ضربا
البلاد وايضا افاد ان هناك جهود
لمحاوله انقاذ عالقنا تحت الانقاض السيد
عزت شاهين عضو مجلس الامناء في هيئه
الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه افادنا قبل
قليل
باخراج شخص على قيد الحياه ووفاه ثلاثه
تحت الانقاض في مبنى دمر جر هذين
الزلزالين الجديدين في دفنه وسمندغ بولايه
هاتاي ومازلنا نتابع معكم هذه الصور
لمحاولات اغاثه على ما يبدو امام هذا
المبنى الذي
دمره ربما الزلزال الاول
والذي ضرب كهرما مراش في السادس من شباط
فبراير الجاري وهذين الزلزلين الجديده
اللذين تسبب بوفاه ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه
مئتين
وثلاثه عشر سيد عزت شاهين في تركيا
عاده عندما يعني ربما هي
امور غريبه قليلا بعد زلزال كبير مدمر ان
يعود ويضرب زلزال نفس المنطقه تقريبا ولكن
ما الاولويه الان بالنسبه لفرق الاغاثه
نعلم بان اخراج من هم على قيد الحياه طبعا
اولويه ولكن بما ان العدد قليل ما الذي
يتبع عمليات الانقاذ واخراج الاحياء من
تحت الانقاض
اظن اهم شيء التاكيد اذا هناك انقاذ قد
وصل خبركم متاخر متاخرا
وهناك طلبات تاتي من عده مناطق في
المكانين الذي ضرب الزلزال اخيرا اكثر من
30 طلبات اداعات قالوا هناك مبنى هدم بشكل
كامل وبقي في الداخل اشخاص او كذا ولكن
رئيس وزير الداخلي هو
نبه الاشخاص عدم الاخبار بدون التاكيد لان
تاتي الاخبار وتحول الرجال او فريق البحث
والانقاذ الى هذه الاماكن ويفقدون الوقت
اذا الخبر ليس صحيح نحن ارسلنا خمسه فريق
الى الاماكن الذي جاء الاخبار والطالبات
باخبار الانقاذ ونحاول ان نتاكد حتى لا
يبقى احد يعني تحت الانقاذ اذا كنت تستطيع
اسمح لي سيتعذب اذا كنت تستطيع ان تتابع
ما يحصل الان هذه الصور التي ننقلها
مباشره منها ما الذي يحاول رجال الانقاذ
فعله الان هل لديك معلومات عن هذا المبنى
تحديدا
ما عندي معلومات دقيقه ان هذا مبنى ولكن
كما تعرف سيدي يعني مئات بل الاف
اعمال البحث رجال البحث وانقاذ كانوا
موجودين في هاتاي لاخراج هم صحيحا وقفوا
بحوث عن الاحياء بعد 15 يوم 16 يوم الا في
منطقه او في
بيتين والباقي كانوا يحاولون اخراج الجثث
من زلزال الاول يعني زلزال قبل اسبوعين
وكانوا موجودين مع 24 سنه 24 ساعه هم
كانوا يعملون على الانقاذ حتى يخرجوا
الجثث ويدفنوا
ولا الزلزال الاخير جاء في نفس الوقت ولكن
لم نسجل او لم نؤكد اذا تضرر من رجال
البحث والاعمال الذين كانوا يعملون لاخراج
الجثث على هذه الانقاذ ولكن حتى نتاكد
ارسلنا فريق كما الحكومه ارسل عده الرجال
الى عده مناطق حتى يتاكدوا لان بعدما قتل
الكهرباء
التاكيد كان صعب شويه والان وكذلك
الانترنت والتلفون ما كان يعمل في بدايه
الامر ولهذا نحن نهتم بكل خبر تاتي من اي
انحاء المدينه حتى نتاكد اذا
الخبر الصحيح واذا بقي احدنا في الانقاذ
شكرا لكما السيد عزه شاهين عضو مجلس
الامناء في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
التركيه والسيد منير مصطفى نائب مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري في شمال سوريا شكرا
لكما عمرو حلبي نعود اليك في ريف حلب
عمرو ايضا المشهد في الخلفيه الناس ترفض
ربما المغادره مغادره الساحات والعوده الى
المنازل نشاهد هذا الشاب الذي يحاول ان
يوزع ربما ما ان ساخنا او شايا على
الموجودين قربنا اكثر من المشهد والخوف
والهلع الذي اصاب
المتواجدين المنكوبين اصلا في ريف حلب
بالفعل جلال ساترك الزميل المصور والصوره
كامله على هذا المشهد وهو جزء من المشهد
العام الكلي الذي يعيشه الناس هنا في ريف
على اليمين ابو الهدى على اليمين هذا
الشاب بالفعل كما ذكرت جلال هو يقوم الان
بتوزيع الشاي الساخن على الناس هنا الذين
بعد الزلزال او بعد الزلزالين رفضوا
العوده الى منازلهم نتيجه كذلك الهزات
الارتداديه
المستمره هذه عده سيارات موجوده هنا في
احدى المناطق في مدينه عزاز في ريف حلب
الشمالي
السيارات هنا موجوده في هذه المنطقه كما
في العديد من المناطق في الطرق في الساحات
بعض الناس في الحدائق القسم الاكبر توجه
الى المخيمات ترى حاله الناس الاطفال
وكاننا عدنا في الحقيقه جلال الى اليوم
الاول من الزلزال الاثنين
وسبحان الله الصدفه ايضا ان اليوم هو
اثنين ايضا
الان الناس عادت من جديد الى الشوارع الى
الحدائق الى الساحات العامه
الناس ترفض العوده الى المنازل وايضا هناك
تحذيرات بالاصل من قبل الدفاع المدني الا
تعود الا يعود الناس الى المنازل خصوصا
تلك المتصدعه او التي تاثرت بالزلزال
والدفاع المدني يقول بان هنالك ابنيه
بالفعل قد انهارت في جنديرس بيريفي حلب
ومناطق اخرى مثل الباب وهنالك اصابات في
الاتارب وغيرها سواء بسقوط حجاره على
الناس نحو 130 جريحا ومصابا في في الباب
والاتارب وجنديرس ومناطق اخرى ايضا في
عموم ريفي حلب عموما حاله الهلع والخوف
الان نستطيع ان نقول انها خفت قليلا لكن
الناس اصبحت عندهم قناعه راسخه هم يرفضون
الذهاب الى المنازل نتيجه
الخوف وكما مثل هذا المشهد تماما هي
الصوره العامه لعموم المدن والبلدات التي
شعرت بهذا الزلزال وكانت وكان زلزالا قويا
سواء الاول او الثاني اللذاني حصلاه قد
نحو ساعه او ساعتين من الان ناهيك عن
شعورهم كذلك بالهزات الارتداديه المستمره
فرقه الدفاع المدني والاسعاف نراها ما بين
الفينه والاخرى تتنقل في الشوارع وتذهب
الى المناطق التي كانت قد تضررت بشكل كبير
من الزلزال الاول جلال ساعود اليك طبعا
عمر حلبي في ريف حلب الان ينضم الينا من
اربد في شمال الاردن الدكتور مصدوق التاج
استاذ الجيولوجيا التركيبيه وعلم الزلازل
في الجامعه الهاشميه دكتور هل هذا امر
مالوف بعد زلزال مدمر بقوه 7.7 يليه زلزال
بسته درجات فاصل اربعه وزلزال اخر بخمسه
فاصل ثمانيه هل هذا النشاط الزلزالي مالوف
في هذه المناطق
نعم اذا تفرجنا على الميكانيكيه الزلزال
هذا الزلزال اللي حصل اليوم مختلف عن
الزلزال الاول
اللي حصل وكانت قوته 87 من عشره فزلدا
اليوم
تفسير طبيعي لحركه الصفيحه لتتحرك الى
الجنوب الغربي اليوم هو اتجاهه شمال شرق
جنوب الغرب تاعته
تشير الى حركه جانبيه مع بسموها يعني
مختلف تماما عن الصدع الاول اللي حصل اللي
كانوا مع شويه هذا مع شويه صار اللي حصل
اليوم زائد مكان مكان هذاك حصل على عشرين
كيلو متر صدى اليوم التحليل الاولي بقول
انه على عشره كيلو متر فزلزالين مختلفين
وزلزال اليوم قد يفسر انه ليس ارتدادي
وانما يتناغم مع حركه صفيحه الاناضول
باتجاه الجنوب الغربي تاع
الزلزال اللي حصل نعم يت اللي قاعد بصير
الان طيب علمنا بحسب شهود عيان وايضا
مراسلين بانه بلبنان بالاردن بفلسطين
شعروا حتى بهذا الزلزال وربما بشكل اكبر
من الزلزال في السادس من شباط لماذا هذا
التوجه جنوبا دكتور وتحديدا على
الساحل حتى في رفح يعني السلطات المصريه
اعلنت ايضا عن بانهم شعروا في رفح بهذا
الزلزال ما التفسير
التفسير هذا الزلزال كان اقرب الى الاردن
ولبنان وسوريا اقرب 150
متر يبعد عن عمان او الاردن حوالي 600
كيلو متر الان هذا الزلزال 450 كيلو متر
فبشعروا فيه بالاردن في حدود ثلاثه ريختار
تقريبا كان هو
سته واربعه من عشره في مكان حصوله لكن كل
ما بعدنا الى الشمال الى الجنوب طبعا
الشده تاعته او القوه تاعته كما يشعر فيها
طبعا يشعر فيها وكانها ثلاثه اختر زائد
حكينا الميكانيكيه مختلفه الميكانيكيه
الزلزال صار اليوم مختلف عن ميكانيكيه
اللي حصل فيها الزلزله ذكرت العمق العمق
كيف يؤثر على شده وقوه الزلزال
كل ما كان العمق اقل عمقا يعني هذا عشره
كيلو متر تاثير السطحي بكون اكثر على
المباني يعني كل ما حصل ده بصير او خماد
للاموات لما تصل للسطح لكن كل مكان قريب
للسطح خاصه الاموال الامواج سطحيه راح
يكون تاثيرها اكثر على البنيان والبنيه
التحتيه والشوارع وما الى ذلك دكتور أعلم
بانكم تقولون بانهم من الصعب التنبؤ بوقوع
زلازل ولكن هذا النشاط في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا وان كان نازل زلين مختلفين بحسب ما
تفضلت ولكن هذا النشاط هل يؤشر الى شيء
اعتقد هذا النشاط راح يستمر كمان اشهر او
يمكن سنوات ما دام بالصفيحه بتتحرك
الزلزال الاول الحركه حسب متر هاي مسافه
مش قليله بالتالي بصير عندي في في تحليل
البسيط جدا راح يصير تنشيط لكثير من
الصدور اللي كانت قبول الخامده ومن هون من
خلالكم كنا اعطي تحذير ثاني لسه في سبعين
اللي حيتحركوا فيه يمكن
الغوص اللي خلينا نقول الصفيحه الافريقيه
الان راح تغوص تحت الصفيحه الاوروبيه قبرص
الان يمكن تتاثر يمكن تصير في خلينا نقول
سحب في الامواج الشاطئيه او خلينا نقول
الصفيحه الافريقيه راح تبدا تغوص تحت
الصفيحه
الاوروبيه فاعتقد راح يصير تنشيط لكثير من
الصدوع يمكن كمان يكون في هذا يصاحبه
تنشيط لصدع الاناضول الشمالي اللي بامر
طبعا في مدينه اسطنبول هذا طوله 1300 كيلو
متر فاعتقد لانه صفيحه الاناضول
باننا نتوقع زلزالا في هذه المناطق صحيح
لا نريد ان نسير القلق لدى المشاهد
الامور بدها حذر خاصه على صدع الامراض
الشمالي اللي قلنا طوله 13 نشيط جدا ويتم
بالزلازل من شده يمكن ثمانيه او اكثر من
ثمانيه فبدها حذر يمكن
بالسنوات القليله القادمه سنه او سنتين
اعتقد راح يصير تنشيط لهذا الصدع طيب شكرا
لك الدكتور مصدوق التاج استاذ الجيولوجيا
التركيبيه وعلم الزلازل في الجامعه
الهاشميه في اربد بشمال الاردن اذا نعود
ونذكركم باننا بتغطيه مفتوحه لزلزالين
جديدين ضرب جنوب تركيا تحديدا فيها تاي في
منطقتي دفنه وسمنداغ بقوه 6.4 درجات وخمسه
فاصل ثمانيه درجات على مقياس ريختر في
منطقتي دفنه وسمنداغ الدياء الى سقوط
ثلاثه واكثر من 213 جريحا في تركيا واكثر
من 100
مصابا في الشمال السوري
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معكم في الحصاد ولدينا ملفات اخرى نذكركم
بابرز الانباء الوارده حتى الان
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
هيئه رصد الكوارث التركيه تعلن وقوع
زلزالين جديدين بقوه
6.4.8 انهيار مباني في مناطق الشمال
السوري والسكان في لبنان وفلسطين والاردن
شعروا بالزلزال
لاول مره الحرب تعهد بمزيد من الدعم
لاوكرانيا ومزيد من العقوبات لروسيا
وازيلنسكي يعتبر زياره اشاره دعم قويه
لبلاده
موسكو تقول ان زياره تمت بعد حصول واشنطن
على ضمانات امنيه والبيت الابيض يقولون
التنسيق كان لتفادي اي سوء تقدير قد يؤدي
لصراع مباشر
تصعد امريكي صيني على خط الحرب في
اوكرانيا بلانكا يحذر بيجين من تزويد
موسكو بالسلاح ويقول انها تدرك مخاطر
الامر والخارجيه الصينيه تقول انها تدعم
محادثات السلام لحل الازمه وتؤكد ان
واشنطن ليست في وضع يسمح لها باخبار بيجين
بما يجب فعله
في تصاعد لمشهد الازمه في تونس مذكره
استدعاء جديده توجه لرئيس البرلمان المنحل
والامين العام السابق لحزب التيار
الديمقراطي حركه النهضه تتهم السلطه
بتوظيف القضاء والمؤسسات الامنيه السياسيا
والاتحاد العام للشغل يدعو لتعبئه شعبيه
في مواجهه السلطه ويقولون الاتحاد سيضطر
لتفعيل مبادره الحوار مع الاحزاب اذا
رفضها الرئيس
[موسيقى]
اذا نعود ونذكر بخبرنا الرئيس في الحصاد
حيث افادت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
ان الزلزلين بقوه
6.4.5.2 على مقياس ريختر ضرب مركز منطقه
دفنه وسمنداغ في ولايه هاتاي جنوبيه
البلاد مساء اليوم واضافت اداره الكوارث
ان سكان مدن هاتاي وغازي عنتاب ومارسين
واضنه وانطاليا وكرما مراش شعروا بالزلزال
وشهد مواطنوا مدن عده ينزلون للشوارع خوفا
من تضرر المباني من اثار الزلزلين وقد شعر
سكان الشمال السوري ولبنان والاردن
وفلسطين بالزلزلين
بينما كان مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج يستعد
لظهور على الهواء من مدينه انطاكيا وقع
الزلزال الجديد حيث وفقت كاميرا الجزيره
لحظات الاولى وهلع السكان في احد مخيمات
انطاكيا حيث يقطنوا منكبو الزلزالين
الان وقع زلزال استمر لثوان
يا الله
[موسيقى]
وفي شمال سوريا افادت الدفاع المدني
السوري باصابه عدد من المدنيين بجروح
متفاوته جراء زلزالها واضاف ان اغلب
الاصابات وقعت بسبب سقوط حجاره او القفز
من الابنيه المرتفعه والتدافع وانهيار
بنايتين متصدعتين غير ماهولتين ومئذنه
مسجد في جنديرس شمالي حلب وعدد من الابنيه
المتصدعه في خربه الجوز والحمزيه والملمنت
والزوف وبيت صوفان غربيه ادلب دون اصابات
فيها كما انهارت جدران وشرف منازل في عده
مدن وبلدات في ريف حلب وفي ادلب ايضا
لشبكه مراسلينا من مركز الزلزال في دفنه
بروايه هاتاي التركيه عمر الحاج ومن غازي
عنتاب براس الجزيره المعتز بلا حسن عمر
كما تابعنا انت وكبت الزلزال
باللحظاته الاولى على الهواء مباشره
كيف كانت الاجواء وحاله الهلع التي اصابت
الموجودين في هذه المناطق التي تضررت من
الزلزلين السابقين والزلزلين الحاليين
يعني جلال حاله الهلع التي رصدناها على
الكاميرا وفي وجوه الاهالي نحن كنا بالقرب
من مدينه خيام كانت قد اعدتها السلطات
التركيه في حي نرلجه القريب من مركز
المدينه انطاكيا هؤلاء السكان بالرغم
بالرغم من وجودهم داخل الخيام اثروا
الخروج حاله من الصراخ الاهالي بدا الكل
يتواصل مع اقاربه لمعرفه ان كان احد منهم
قد تضرروا اولادهم بعد ذلك سارعت فرقه
الشرطه
للتوجه الى المناطق التي تم الاخبار عنها
ان هناك بعض العالقين على ذكر ذلك نحن
تحولنا الى مركز المدينه هنا الى مدينه
انطاكيا هذا المكان كان قد نشبت فيه حريق
عقب الزلزال بعد سيطرته قوات بعد سيطره
مكافحه الحرائق على المكان كان هناك بحث
عن
عالقين محتملين في هذا المكان لكن بعد
سؤال الاهالي وسؤال صاحب المنزل قررت
السلطات ان في سبيل السيطره على الحريق
وخوفا من اي تسرب للغاز انها ستهدم هذا
المسجد كما تشاهدون عمليات الهدم الان
بدات
من قبل
قوه من قبل عمال مكافحه الطوارئ الافاد
اضافه الى اشراف من الجيش
الوزير وزير الداخليه سليمان صويلو كان قد
تحدث في وقت سابق عن وقوع ثلاثه قتله
نتيجه الزلزال الاخيره الذي كان مركزه
مدينه دفنه وتحدث عنه
مصابا نتيجه هذا الزلزال السلطات سارعت
الى اخلاء مؤسسات رئيسيه على راسها مستشفى
مصطفى كمال هنا الرئيسي في مدينه انطاكيا
اضافه الى اخلاء مشفى اسكندرون الوطني
الكبير من المصابين فيه من المرضى كذلك
الامر مركز مركز اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
نفسه في انطاكيا تم اخلاقه من قبل
العاملين هناك كانت هناك تحذيرات من هزات
اخرى اقوى التذكيرا بما حدث الزلزال الذي
وقع بقوه 6.4 كان مركزه دفنه البعيده عن
مركز المدينه انطاكيا خمسه كيلومترات فقط
ثم بعد ذلك التلهجال بقوه 5.8 مركزهم
مدينه سمنداخ
نداءات انطلقت كما ذكرنا
لانقاذ عالقين محتملين سواء في دفنه او
حتى في سمنداخ نحن وصلنا الى دفنه تحدثنا
الى رجال
الدفاع المدني وايضا اداره الطوارئ قالوا
ان هناك العشرات من الانباء عن عالقين
محتمرين ولكن الكثير من هذه الاخطارات او
هذه النداءات اتضح انها غير دقيقه ولكنها
مستمره في العمل الامر كذلك في صمناغ وان
كان رئيس بلديه حطاي الكبرى اضافه الى
رئيس بلديه سمندغ اكدوا وجود عالقين تحت
الانقاض كما تشاهدون
كان هناك حديث عن عانقين محتملين ولكن في
سبيل السيطره على تسرب محتمل لالغاز او
حتى او الحريق دلاع حريق مره اخرى اثرت
السلطات ان تشارع في هد المنزل الذي كان
اصلا متصدعا وقد اعلن انه مصاب باضرار
كبيره وغير صالح
للسكن او للعوده مره اخرى للاهالي
الكهرباء بالمناسبه في جني الولايه ليس
فقط في مركز الولايه مدينه انطاكيا هناك
حديث عن انهيار منازل سواء في نار التي
كنا فيها بدايه او في التنوز او في مناطق
اخرى دفن الحقيقه جلال اذا كان من الوقت
لنصف المشاهد وصلنا اليها بصعوبه بالغه
الكثير من الركام كان على جانبي الطريق في
داخل الاحياء وعلى هذه القله هناك اضافه
الى موظفي الافاد موظفي اداره الكوارث
قالوا لنا ان الكثير من هذه الابنيه كان
متصدعا وانهارا عند وقوع الزلزال ولا
غرابه لان
كبيره جدا والكثير وفقا لي من الابنيه
وفقا للسلطات المحليه في وقت سابق للسقوط
او انه مقابل السقوط في اي هزه وين كانت
بسيطه
اربعه ووقعت في مركز المدينه في مدينه
دفنه كذلك الامر في مدينه سمنداخ والسلطات
ما تزال تاخذ بجديه كل التحذيرات او كل
نداءات يتحدث عن وجود عالقنا محتملين تحت
الانقاض نتيجه الزلزالين الاخيرين الذين
وقعا في ولايه هاتاي طيب ينضم الينا عمر
حلبي ايضا من ريف حلبي ينضم الى شبكه
مراسلينا الان في غازي عنتاب المعتز بله
حسن افدتنا في الساعه الاولى من الحصاد
بانه لا اصابات في غازي عنتاب ولكن ماذا
عن الجو العام في غازي عنتاب التي دمرت
اصلا بشكل كبير جراء الزلزال المدمر في
السادس من شباط وما الذي حصل بعد وقوع
الزلزلين الاخيرين
[موسيقى]
لدينا مشكله في الصوت معك المعتز بالله
اعتذر منك لدينا مشكله في الصوت سنحاول حل
هذه المشكله وساعود اليك في غازي عنتاب
طيب امر حلبي في ريف حلب ايضا نقلت لنا
الصوره وحاله الهلع لدى الناس في الساحات
الذين يرفضون العوده الى منازلهم او على
الاقل مراكز اللواء الذين التي يبيتون
فيها جراء الزلزال السابق اطلعنا على
الوضع الان كيف هو
يعني جلال في الحقيقه دعني فقط اصف لك
لحظات الاولى من وقوع هذا الزلزال يعني
وكاننا عدنا الى اليوم الاول من الزلزال
الكبير لكن نحن كنا في السياره متجهين من
مدينه اعزاز باتجاه مدينه عفرين حتى
تحضيرا لمقابله على نشره التاسعه نحن في
السياره كنا نرى جموع الناس تغادر الابنيه
وتقطع السياره الطرقات امامنا توقفنا
فاحسسنا معهم كذلك في الزلزال وعندما
توقفنا كذلك كان زلزال الثاني الذي كان
بشده خمسه فاصله ثمانيه حاله الهلع والرعب
والخوف الموجوده في لدى الناس عند اللحظات
الاولى والدقائق الاولى بعيده الزلزالين
وكانك تشاهد فيلما عن نهايه العالم الان
الحاله النفسيه لدى الناس هدات لكن سادع
الكاميرا تريكه هذه السيارات الموجوده هنا
على قارعه الطريق في احد الشوارع الرئيسيه
في مدينه اعزاز لاناس
هربوا من نتيجه
الهزات ونتيجه الزلزالين وما تلاهما من
هزات ارتداديه
يخافون ويخشون العوده الى منازلهم وكذلك
السيارات التي الان تمشي في الحقيقه انا
الان اشاهد سيارات هي تمشي لكن وجهتها غير
معروفه يعني كل سياره هي تقوم بتشغيل ضوء
الرباعي للسياره وتنظر الى مكان مناسب حتى
تصف فيه وتقضي ليلتها مع العائله هذا ما
يخص العوائل التي لديها سيارات اما اناس
اخرون فاتجهوا باتجاه مخيمات سواء نزوح
الاولى وعندنا في شمال غربي سوريا كما
تعلم 1600 مخيم تقريبا
باقي باقي الناس اتجهوا باتجاه مخيمات
الايواء التي احدثت قبل ايام نتيجه
الزلزال الاول الذي ضرب المنطقه هنا عموما
حاله الهلع تقريبا خفت لدى الناس والامور
بدات تعود تدريجيا الحياه تدريجيا الى
سابقها لكن دون ان يعود الناس الى منازلهم
خوفا من هزات
ارتداديه تحصل في اي لحظه وكما ذكرت لك
نحن نشعر بهزات خفيفه ما بين 2000 والاخرى
عموما الدفاع المدني السوري يقول بان
هنالك ابنيه قد انهارت في جنديرس بريف حلب
في منطقه عفرين تحديدا لكن لم يسفر ذلك عن
وقوع اصابات نظرا لان المدينه اصلا معظم
سكانها قد نزحوا منها والابنيه التي
انهارت كانت خاليه من السكان هنالك اصابات
نحو 130 اصابه نتيجه
وقوع وسقوط حجاره على مدنيين على الناس في
الشوارع اضافه الى ان اناس عديدون اصيبوا
بعد ان قفزوا من شروفات منازلهم خوفا
وهلعا من الزلزال المشكله جلال ليست فقط
في هذا المشهد الان انما نحن نتحدث يعني
بعد ان حصل الزلزال الاول كان هناك حديث
عن الهزات الارتجاديه وتحذيرات من ان هزات
اخرى سوف تقع وتصل شدتها ما بين 6 الى 6.5
على مقياس ريختر والان هذه الهزه القويه
التي حصلت سوف تعزز وترسخ الرعب في قلوب
الناس ويخشون من العوده الى منازلهم وكثير
من المنازل اصلا هي متصدعه ومتشقق وقد
اصابتها التشققات في العديد من المناطق
شمال غربي سوريا خصوصا في ريف حلب ايضا
جلال نعم المعتز بالله اعود اليك في غزه
عنتاب الوضع بشكل عام عاقبه الزلزلين فيها
جلال كان هناك حاله ربما من الخوف بعد
الزلزال الذي ضرب اليوم نحن شعرنا بهذا
الزلزال في مدينه غازي عنتاب وعلمنا بعدها
ان شدته 6.4 هزه
اخرى.
هذين الزلزالين وما اعاقبهما من هزات
ارتداديه تسببا بحاله من الخوف لدى السكان
لذلك راينا في الساعه التي هذا الزلزال
خروج كثير من المواطنين في مدينه غازي
عنتاب الى الشوارع وكان هناك ايضا
محاولات لدى البعض للتوجه لمحطات الوقود
من اجل التزود بالوقود حاله وهو الحال
الذي يحصل عاده بعد الهزات الكبيره لان
هناك اشخاص
يقضون الليل في سياراتهم خشيه وقوع هزات
جديده لكن محافظ غازي عنتاب تحدث وقال انه
لا اضرار في المدينه وان
فقط جزء من مبنى مهجور هو ما سقط وطلب
الناس بالابتعاد عن الاماكن المتضرره
والابنيه المتضرره دعنا نذكر ما الذي حدث
في غازي عنتاب بعد زلزالين الكبيرين الذين
ضربا في السادس من الشهر الجاري كان هناك
اضرار في منطقه مدينه نورداغ ومناطق اخرى
في غازي عنتاب
وهذه المدينه مدينه مدينه التابعه
للمحافظه هي تضررت بشكل كبير حتى ان معظم
هذه المباني الموجوده في المدينه هي اتخذ
قرار بهدمها وهناك وبالتالي هناك اضرار
كبيره وهذا ما يجعل القلق هو سمه واضحه مع
وجود اي هزه ارتداديه في مدينه غازي عنتاب
لكن الان بعد تصريح او تغريده التي
ذكرها محافظ المدينه الاوضاع تبدو اهدى
وافضل في مدينه غازي شكرا لكم على معتز
بالله في غازي عنتاب عمر حلبي في ريف حلب
وعمر الحاج في دفنه في تركيا
على واقع الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وشمالي
سوريا والهزات الارتداديه مساء الاثنين
هرع الاهالي في مدينه عفرين الى الطرقات
والساحات العامه خوفا من هزات ارتداديه
جديده عمر حوراني رصد جانبا من ذلك في
التقرير التالي
نحن هنا في هذا الملعب وسط مدينه عفرين
حيث هرع الاهالي هنا الى هذا الملعب بعد
حدوث الزلزال والهزه الارتداديه كما نشاهد
الاهالي يفترشون هذا الملعب في الارض جراء
هذا الزلزال وهناك مخاوف من استمرار
الهزات الارتداديه وسط عدم توفر خيام لهذه
العائلات لكي تبيت ليلتها فيها وذلك هم
اصلا كانوا من المتضررين جراء
الزلزالين والهزات الارتداديه منذ السادس
من هذا الشهر وما زالوا وما زالت المعاناه
مستمره من خلال نقص الخيام نقص نقص
الايواء ونقص التغذيه في هذا المكان اذا
هي حاله ماساويه يشهدها الشمال السوري
وذلك مع استمرار نقص المساعدات
وجاءت وجاء هذا الزلزال والهزات
الارتداديه هذا اليوم ليفاقم من المعاناه
حيث رصدناها حاله هلع كبيره اعادتنا
للحظات الاولى للحدوث الزلزال الاول في
السادس من شباط الجاري
عمر الحوراني الجزيره
من مدينه عفرين بريف حلب
ضيفينا في هذه التغطيه من غازي عنتاب
المهندس قاسم شوبك مدير وحده المعلومات في
وحده تنسيق الدعم وفي اسطنبول السيد عبد
الله الطاي مدير الدبلوماسيه الانسانيه في
هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه سيد الطاي هل تم
احتواء تداعيات الزلزلين الجريدين في
هاتاي بتقديرك
المعلومات الاوليه تشير سيدي الى ان عدد
الضحايا قليل حتى لو اخذنا عدد الخسائر
لان اغلب البنايات كانت فارغه حتى جزء ليس
بالقليل من الضحايا
هم كانوا بسبب الهلع وليس بسبب انهم تحت
الانقاض نحن ما زال لدينا تخاف الى الان
التخوفات لم تنتهي دعني اشير الى نقطه
مهمه وهي ان اغلب المدن المتضرره لجا
اهاليها الى الريف الريف تضرر من الزلازل
الاولى رغم ان عدد الطوابق السكنيه قليله
لكن ربما في هذا الزلزال او في هذا الهزه
اصبحت هناك خسائر اخرى لذلك
فرقنا ما زالت لم تصل الى كامل الريف نحن
الان في عمليه المسح متخوفون من الريف بكل
صراحه لان اذا تكلمنا عن بيت قبل الزلزال
قبل سته
شباط كان يسكن فيه خمسه اشخاص سنت ربما عن
عائلتان ثلاثه في ذلك المنزل ما زالت
عمليات المسح لم تنتهي هناك حالات
من الهلع رمت بنفسها ربما من الشرفه يتكلم
عن بعض الحالات ليست كثيره هناك
حالات اصابها اعياء او او بسبب الهرب
تضررت لكن فعليا البحث بالارقام جاري في
منطقه واحده في مدينه تاتاي بواسطه فرق
افاد اما فرقنا نحن في الاهات فهي توجهت
الى الريف اكثر اذا كنت ساشير الى شيء جدا
مهم الان نحتاجه اكثر من اي وقت مضى في
هذه الاسبوعين
تم تهيئه الناس نسبيا وتعودوا حتى اذا كنت
ساكون اكثر وضوحا اليوم في تركيا كانت
الاجنده عن الاعمار ما الذي سيحدث لكن بعد
الزلزال الذي حدث الان نحن سنحتاج عدد خيم
اكبر بكثير سنحتاج منازل متنقله اكبر
بكثير
بعض قليل فقط اشير الى عندما تشيرون الى
عدد الضحايا قليل جراء هذين الزلزلين هو
مقارنه طبعا
بالعدد الكبير من الضحايا جراء زلزال
كهرمان مراش المدمر سيد قاسم شوبك ما الذي
يمكن ان ينتج عن هذين الزلزلين من معاناه
اضافيه في الشمال السوري
سيدي الكريم هناك حاله نزوح كبيره ما قبل
الزلزال والزلزال الاول ايضا سبب حاله
كبيره يفوق 86 الف شخص تشرد خلال الاسدال
الكبير الذي حصل في سته شباط فالحاله
الجديده التي عشناها اليوم ايضا سببت في
حاله نزوح كمان طارئه وجديده فهناك ايضا
تشرد وبات الناس الان في العراء دون خيام
دون بطانيات دون فرش هذا الامر بالتاكيد
سوف يؤثر على انتشار حالات امراض خاصه عند
الاطفال الرضع وعند المرضعات والحوامل
فيجب ان يكون هناك استجابه فوريه وطارئه
من اجل تدارك الوضع والا نحن معرضون
لانتشار عدد جديد من الاوبئه في ظل
الاختزاز السكاني وتشرد الناس في العراق
المساعدات التي دخلت حتى الان سواء كانت
طبيه او او اغاثيه هل هل هي على مستوى
المطلوب سيد قاسم
بالتاكيد ليست على المستوى المطلوب صراحه
المعونات والمساعدات التي دخلت حجمها ضئيل
جدا بالنسبه الى حجم الاحتياج حتى الان
قرابه مئتين شاحنه تم ادخالها الى سوريا
من المساعدات الامميه وهناك عده مساعدات
قادمه من الدول العربيه من
بعض المنظمات الدوليه لكن هذا الحجم من
المساعدات بالتاكيد غير كافي نتيجه حاله
التشرد وحاله النزوح التي يعيشها الناس
اضف الى ذلك حاله الاقتراب والقلق الذي
يعيشه عمال موظفي المنظمات الانسانيه
العاملين في جنوب تركيا في غازي عنتاب
وفيها طيب بشكل خاص كونها مقرا لمعظم
المنظمات الدوليه والاماميه ايضا في شمال
غرب سوريا معظم الفرق الفرق المنظمات
الانسانيه ايضا هم بحاله نزوح يعني لا
يستطيعون التعامل مع اسرهم هم في الشوارع
فهناك حاله كبيره يجب الاستجابه اليها
والكمل داخل الى الان من المساعدات
بالتاكيد لا يك هناك تقديرات الى انها لا
تغطي الا 8% يعني من الاحتياج الحالي قبل
ان نعود للسيد الطاي اشير ان هذه الصور
التي تنقل مباشره الان بكاميرا الجزيره هي
لهذا المبنى الذي شب فيه حريق هو كان اصلا
مدمر جزئيا وغير صالح للسكن بحسب ما افاد
قبل قليل عمر الحاج المتواجد في هذه
المنطقه تحديدا وفرق هنا الاغاثه والانقاذ
تحاول بان تدمر هذا المبنى لانه غير قابل
للسكن بطبيعه الحال وقد نشب فيه حريق جراء
الزلزلين في هاتاي سيد الطاي هزات
ارتداديه كثيره قدرت بالمئات منذ زلزال
كهرمان مراش وزلزلين ايضا جديدين فيها تاي
هذه الهزات والزلازل هل تؤثر على مخطط
السلطات التركيه في هذه المرحله التاليه
من بعد الزلزال المدمر في كهرما المراش
بالطبع سيدي في حال عدم استقرار المنطقه
في احسن الاحوال قد نلجا فقط الى رفع
الانقاض لكن اعاده البناء يتطلب ان تكون
المنطقه اكثر استقرارا
هذا شيء واقعي الذي اسمعه الان خاصه بعد
الهزات من الخبراء هو في اطار انه هناك
هزات اخرى ستحدث في تركيا ربما لن تكون
اقل من الذي حدثت
بطبيعه الحال هذا يجعل الشركات التي ستعيد
الاعمار او
حتى الحكومه التركيه ستتريس اكثر لكن
عمليات رفع الانقاض بحد ذاتها لن تكون
قصيره هي ستاخذ وقت كبير اذا اخذنا بنظر
الاعتبار عشر ولايات متضرره ثلاثه منها
ضررها جدا كبير
وفي هذه الحاله في حال بانكم تتوقعون هزات
اخرى ارتداديه وربما زلازل ايضا في هذه
المنطقه هذا ما الذي يضيفه عليكم
كجهات اغاثيه
وسلطات تحاول ان تخفف من وطات ومعاناه
المنكوبين هناك
نحن على الاقل كاستجابه سريعه للعمليات
الانسانيه الان عقدنا غرفه عمليات جديده
رغم اننا ودعنا كثير من الفرق الاغاثه
اليوم من البوسنه ومن السودان ومن العراق
ومن الدول الغربيه الا اعد الا اننا اعدنا
ارسال اشاره الاستعداد مره اخرى ربما ليس
لنفس الفرق او لفرق رديفه
نحن بنفس الوقت كان لدينا تبديل لفرقنا
قبل يومين هذه الفرق الان ايضا مجهزه
لاحظتم في بدايه الهزه
كان هناك تحذير لارتفاع نسبه المياه طبعا
اذا تكلمنا عن عن عن عن هزه او زلزال في
البحر فهذه تتطلب اشياء غير التي يتطلبها
لانقاذ العادي فنحن
بما ان التحذير صدر جهزنا وتركناها جاهزه
النجاد
[موسيقى]
ات المائيه وغيرها من الامور التي شكرا
تناسب الفيضان اكثر من الزلزال شكرا لكما
عبد الله مدير الدبلوماسيه الانسانيه في
اسطنبول والسيد المهندس قاسم شوبك مدير
وحده المعلومات في وحده تنسيق الدعم في
غازي عنتاب شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
اذا نتابع في ملفات اخرى من اوكرانيا حيث
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خلال زيارته
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه انه سيتم الاعلان
في وقت لاحق هذا الاسبوع عن عقوبات اضافيه
ضد نخب وشركات روسيه واشار الى ان هناك
تحالفا يضم 50 دوله لدعم اوكرانيا قال
رئيس الاوكراني بولو دينسكي انه يمكن
تحويل العام الجاري الى عامل للنصر ضد
روسيا مؤكدا على اهميه الفوز في هذه
المعركه التي وصفها بالتاريخيه
تاريخيه واستراتيجيه هكذا وصفت اوكرانيا
زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
زياره موسقت مسبقا مع موسكو وجرت بعد رحله
استغرقت 10 ساعات على متن قطار قادم من
بولندا وهي تاتي عشيه دخول الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا عامها الثاني وبعد المباحثات
جرى اعلان دعم امريكي اضافي لاوكرانيا
مقابل عقوبات اضافيه على روسيا لذلك
بنينا تحالفا من شمال الاطلسي الى المحيط
الهادئ يضم النيتو اليابان وعبر العالم
اكثر من 50 دوله ساعدت اوكرانيا وامنت لها
دعما اقتصاديا وعسكريا وانسانيا غير مسبوق
في وقت لاحقين من هذا الاسبوع سنعلن عن
عقوبات اضافيه ضد النخب والشركات التي
تحاول التهرب من العقوبات ودعم اله الحرب
الروسيه
الرئيس الاوكراني
الذي وصف محادثاته مع بايدن بالمثمره اكد
ان نتائج هذه الزياره ستكون ملموسه في
تعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه لبلاده
يمكننا ويجب علينا ان نجعل هذا العام عام
النصر هذه الحرب الاجراميه تغير المبررته
روسيا ضد اوكرانيا وكل اوروبا والعالم
الديمقراطي يجب ان تنتهي بتطهير الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من الاحتلال الروسي جنبا الى
جنب مع السيد الرئيس بايدن ومع حلفائنا
وشركائنا يجب ان نواصل بدل كل ما في وسعنا
حتى يفوز العالم الديمقراطي في هذه
المعركه التاريخيه
ويترقب الاوكرانيون طبيعه الدعم الامريكي
الجديد وتداعياته على المعارك المحتدمه
على اكثر من محور وجبهه لاسيما مع التوقع
اوكرانيا معارك اضافيه في المرحله المقبله
جدا وخصوصا ان اوكرانيا تستعد لهجوم مضاد
لاستعاده المزيد من الاراضي وتبعث هذه
الزياره رساله هامه وقويه لروسيا او
للشركاء ايضا بان دعم الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا في اعلى مستوياته
وبينما كان بايضا يزور قلب العاصمه ويضع
اكليلا من الزهر امام الجدار التذكاري
لقتل الحرب كانت صفارات الانذار تداوي في
ارجائها
[موسيقى]
فكياف ما زالت في عين العاصفه بعد مرور
عام على وصول القوات الروسيه الى ابوابها
قبل الانسحاب لاحقا سيناريو تتاهب
اوكرانيا لمواجهه احتمال تكراره
زياره مفاجاه للرئيس الامريكي الى
اوكرانيا حملت الكثير من الدلالات
والرمزيه والاهم انها حملت دعما سياسيا
وعسكريا ومعنويا اضافيا تتطلع اليه كياف
عشيه دخول الحرب الروسيه عليها عامها
الثاني كاترين حنا الجزيره كياف
يذهب لنا السيد
وهو متواجد في بوسطن في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سيد تيموفي بالحديث عن دعم
بالاسلحه جديد من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا
هل سيتم تزويد كياف بالاسلحه بعيده المدى
كما تطالب بعد زياره الرئيس الامريكي الى
كياف
امل ذلك امل ذلك بالفعل حيث ان ذلك سوف
ينقذ الارواح وسوف تنتهي الحرب بفتره اقرب
ولكن يتعين علينا ان ننتظر لنرى المده
الزمنيه ولكن يعني هل هل سمع الرئيس
الاوكراني زينينسكي من نظيره الامريكي
وعودا بهذا الشان
نعم لقد استمع الى وعود ونحن ممتنون ازاء
كل الدعم
ويمكنكم ان تشاهدوا من خلال الخطابات ان
الرئيس يسلط الضوء بشكل مستمر على اهميه
تقديم الدعم المناسب بشكل سريع لانه في كل
مره يتاخر الدعم يموت الناس طيب كيف يمكن
لاوكرانيا ان تصرف هذه الزياره على الواقع
في في الميدان لانه نعلم بان وبحسب
السلطات الاوكرانيه الحال بان الوضع على
الجبهات صعب جدا لسيما في بخموت مثلا او
في المناطق الشرقيه بالتالي كيف يمكن صرف
هذه السياره السياسيه على الواقع في
الميدان
انت على حق الوضع صعب بخصوصا في محيطي
محمود القوات الروسيه تقوم
بالتقدم من دون التنبه الى ارواحي الجنود
الروس لا يابهون اذا ما قتلوه ولكن حتى
اللحظه الراهنه القوات الاوكرانيه
باستطاعتها ان تحافظ على خط الدفاع
بالنسبه الى الزياره السياسيه هناك رمزيه
حيث اننا نتحدث عن الذكرى الاولى
للحرب مرور السنه هذه زياره سياسيه ولكن
هذا هذه الزياره الرمزيه تساعد على حشد
الدعم من حلفاء اخرين حتى من داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن هذا
الامر يتطلب وقتا لكي نرى ذلك مترجما في
الميدان في ميدان المعركه ادله تداعيات او
النتائج العمليه لهذه الزياره سوف نراها
في الاشهر المقبله ولكنعكاسات التي ترجوها
كياف من هذه الزياره للرئيس الامريكي
الاكياف
نحن نطلب المزيد من الذخيره وطبعا نطلب
الدبابات كما ظهر في الاعلام بالاضافه الى
اسلحه بعيده المدى ونطالب بدفاعات جويه
افضل ونحن بحاجه الى سلاح الجو او دعم
بجوي رغم مقاله
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه بانها ضمانات
امنيه قدمتها موسكو
لزياره الرئيس بايدن الى كيافي لان صفارات
الانذار دوت
فيكياف خلال تواجد الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن هناك ما الرساله الروسيه بالتقدير
الاوكراني
الوضع دائما هكذا مع روسيا وحصل ذلك في كل
مفاوضات منذ العام 2014 نتذكر اتفاقيات
تفاوضنا لمرتين وكان هناك بعثات دفاعيه
وبعت فرنسيه بعثه المانيه كانوا يلتقون في
الوقت نفسه روسيا كانت تستمر بقصف القوات
الاوكرانيه في الاجزاء الشرقيه من البلاد
دائما تقوم روسيا بذلك في خلال زياره
دبلوماسيه اي زياره دبلوماسيه تحاول روسيا
ان تضغط بشكل متزايد براي هذه
الاستراتيجيه سوف ترتد على الروس وسوف
تكون لصالح اوكرانيا الناس يشاهدون ما
تقوم به روسيا ويعرفون روسيا على حقيقتها
وهذا يساعد اوكرانيا شكرا لك تيموفي
موليفانوف مستشاره الرئيس الاوكراني
نتابع في نفس الموضوع تنضم الينا من موسكو
الينا الباحثه والمحلله السياسيه السيده
ايلينا ما دلاله اكتفاء الخارجيه الروسيه
بالاشاره الى التنسيق الامني والضمانات
الامنيه كما سمتها ماريا زخرفه لزياره
الرئيس بيضا والاشاره ايضا الى مصير
الرئيس الجورجي السابق سخشفيلي
مساء الخير نعم روسيا اعطت الضوء الاخضر
لزياره بايدن الى كيا وهذا من مفارقات
العلاقات الحاليه ما بين روسيا وامريكا
واوكرانيا لانه امريكانا هم طلبوا هذه
الضمانات وهذا يعني وهذا مهم انه قنوات
الاتصال هي ما زالت موجوده نحن عده مرات
تعرفنا عن وجود هذه القنوات مثلا والتبادل
السجناء ما بين روسيا وامريكا الان هذا هو
دليل اضافي على انه هذه القنوات ما زالت
موجوده رغم انها ضيق جدا
وتستخدم ليست دائما بالنسبه لرئيس جورج
الصادق
روسيا الان تستخدم
هو
كاحد الامثله بانه امريكان هم لديهم سياسه
ازدواجيه المعايير الى انهم دعموا في منذ
زمن طويل هذا الشخص السياسي ولكن فيما بعد
تركوه بعد ما تم استخدامه من قبل
الامريكان هذا التلميح الى انه مصير
زيلانسكي ممكن ان يكون مشابها هل هذا يعني
بالضروره بان موسكو تريد الان ازاحه
الرئيس زيننسكي عن رئاسه اوكرانيا من خلال
هذا التلميح لمصير سخشفيلي
لا ابدا هذا لا يعني ذلك بالعكس هذا يعني
انه هناك ايضا كانت ضمانات معينه من قبل
موسكو تجاه رئيس اوكرانيا لان ما قاله منذ
بضعه ايام رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق
يشير الى انه اوكرانيا وامريكا التي
وراءها
طلبت من روسيا نفس الضمانات لانني لن اخفي
عليكم كانت هناك بعض المقترحات في داخل
روسيا وبعد التساؤلات لماذا لم يتم
استهداف الرئيس الاوكراني طالما هو عدوه
وهناك حاله المواجهه العسكريه ولكن كما
يبدو الرئيس الروسي اعطى هذه الضمانات
ايضا وقال انه لن يتم ذلك الى جانب
المغزى السياسي والمعنوي لهذه الزياره
الرئيس بايدن اشار من كياف الى تحالف يضم
50 دوله
لدعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا هذا الواقع
هل يعني بان موسكو في عزله دوليه الان
امام هذا التحالف لدعم اوكرانيا
لا ابدا وحتى تحليلات غربيه تشير الى انه
عزله روسيا امر مستحيل نحن الان منذ
عبيدات ايام بعد انتهاء مؤتمر ميونخ في
المانيا فهم حضروا دراسه تحليليه مفصله
حول هذه المساله وقالوا وعبروا عن تاسفهم
بسبب عدم انعزال وعزلت روسيا عزل روسيا
وقالوا ان هناك بلدان عندي تريد ما زالت
تتعاون مع روسيا بما فيها دول عربيه
وافريقيه في امريكا اللاتينيه ايضا وفي
اسيا ما بينها الصين والهندا
ودول عربيه متعدده بما فيها قطر لديها
علاقات مع روسيا
مؤتمر ميونيخ الشعر الى انه هذا الامر
سيستمر لانه دول كثيره تريد ان تتعاون مع
روسيا باسباب متعدده شكرا لك الينا
الباحثه والمحلله السياسيه في موسكو
في مجالات متعدده وبواتيره تصاعديه استمر
الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا منذ اليوم الاول
للحرب الروسيه رغم ذلك تؤكد واشنطن انها
حريصه على عدم الخوض في مواجهه مباشره مع
موسكو اشكال ومراحل الدعم الامريكي
لاوكرانيا نتعرف عليها في التقرير التالي
منذ الايام الاولى من الحرب كان وقوف
الولايات المتحده مع اوكرانيا واضحا دعم
عسكري واستخبارات وسياسي واقتصادي لكن دون
الدخول في مواجهه مباشره مع موسكو لم ياتي
الدعم المذكور دفعه واحده واقتصر في
البدايه على دعم عسكري بقيمه 350 مليون
دولار متضمنا وقتها مضادات للدروع واسلحه
خفيفه انتهى المطاف بدعم بلغ حتى يومنا
هذا اكثر من سته وعشرين مليار دولار
والحديث بات يشمل الدبابات ابرامز وصواريخ
طويله المدى ومنظومات باتريوت وهايمارس في
الشق الاقتصاد الضاغط على روسيا كانت
العقوبات التي تحاول تضييق الخناق على
روسيا وتطورت الى حد سمحت في واشنطن باول
عمليه نقل لاصول مصادره تتبع جهات روسيه
وبتحويلها الى اوكرانيا
سياسيا كانت هناك زيارات متلاحقه بدلا من
وزيري الخارجيه والدفاع ورئيسه مجلس
النواب السابق ناصر بيلوسي واحدثها دون شك
زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
قادت واشنطن عمليه لحشد الدعم السياسي
وتوحيد الجبه الغربيه في كثير من المراحل
في وجه روسيا ودعما لاوكرانيا وقد كان
مؤتمر الدعم في قاعده رامشتاين الالمانيه
الاكبر وقد شاركت فيه اربعون دوله بدعوه
امريكيه
[موسيقى]
جدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مخاوف بلاده
والمجتمع الدولي من احتمال ان تزود الصين
روسيا باسلحه فتاكه لاستخدامها في الحرب
على اوكرانيا وحذر من ان ذلك سيضر
بالعلاقات معها وقد نفت بجين تلك
الاتهامات قائله ان واشنطن تمارس التضليل
وتصب الزيت على النار وفي سياق متصل قال
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تزويد الصين روسيا
باسلحه سيكون خطا احمر في العلاقه بين
الجانبين
لطالما كانت تقارب الصيني الروسي المتسارع
في السنوات الاخيره تحت مجهر الغرب لكن مع
اشتعال الحرب في اوكرانيا تحولت الريبه
الى مخاوف ثم اتهامات في الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب بان بيجين تستعد لتسليح
موسكو
قد يكون من دعم الصين في مساعي روسيا في
الحرب على اوكرانيا وخاصه بالاسلحه ونراقب
ذلك عن كثب وكما قال الرئيس بايدن خلال
حديثهم مع الرئيس الصيني انه سيكون لذلك
انعكاسات على العلاقات بين امريكا والصين
اذا زودت الصين روسيا بالاسلحه في عدوانها
على اوكرانيا او في حال خلقها للعقوبات
الرد على الاتهامات الامريكيه تكفلت به
الخارجيه الصينيه نافيه اياها جمله
وتفصيله
الولايات المتحده وليس الصين هي من يزود
ساحه المعركه بالاسلحه دونما توقف
والولايات المتحده ليست في وضع يسمح لها
باعطاء اوامر للصين ولن نقبل ابدا توجيه
اصابع الاتهام او الاكراه والضغط على
الصين وروسيا لا تكتفي بجيل برد التهم بل
تذهب الى حد التاكيد انها بصدد اصدار ورقه
موقف بشان التسويه السياسيه للحرب في
اوكرانيا تزامنا مع الذكرى السنويه الاولى
للاندلاعها
احتمال تقديم الصين دعما فتاكا لروسيا كما
يقول الامريكيون كان محور النقاش في
اجتماع سابق الاحد بين انطوني بلينكل
ونظيره الصيني وانجي في ميونخ على هامش
مؤتمر حول الامن تلك المخاوف سرعان ما
تلقفها الاوروبيون ايضا غداه اجتماعي
وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد في بروكسل
على
اعربت ان قلقنا الشديد بشان قيام الصين
بتقديم اسلحه لروسيا وطلبت من وانجي عدم
القيام بذلك لم نعبر عن قلقنا فحسب بل عن
حقيقه انه بالنسبه لنا سيكون خطا احمر في
علاقتنا مع الصين
تنام الضغوط الغربيه والامريكيه على الصين
يبدو اقرب الى اجراء استباقي لثنيها عن اي
تعاون عسكري مع الروس بينما تتحدث كيف
وحلفائها عن حسم عسكري خلال العام الحالي
وبالنظر الى ان شراكه بيجين الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه مع اوروبا والولايات المتحده
اكبر بكثير من تلك التي تربطها بموسكو فان
تلك الضغوط هي تذكير لها وتحذير في الان
نفسه من العواقب التجاريه الوخيمه التي قد
تتكبدها في حال اي عقوبات ضدها فهل يضيق
الخناق على الصين فعلا ام ان بمقدورها
دائما ايجاد صيغه الملائمه للحفاظ على
مصالحها مع كل الخصوم مستظله بموقفها
الغامض من الحرب التي امتنعت حتى الان عن
تاييدها او انتقادها
قال رئيس وزراء مولدوفا الجديد دورن
ريسيان انه يجب نزع سلاح اقليم
الانفصالي وطرد القوات الروسيه منه وتاتي
هذه التصريحات عقب احتجاجات نظمها حزب شور
الموالي لروسيا في الاقليم ضد حكومه
مولدوفا للمطالبه باستقاله السلطات
الحاكمه نتعرف اكثر على الاقليم في
التقرير التالي
هذا الشريط الضيق الشرقي مولدوفا هو ما
يطلق عليه اقليم ترانستستيريا البالغه
مساحته نحو 4000
لا يخضع هذا الاقليم لسيطره السلطات
المولدوفيه منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
عام
1992 ويحكمهم فيصاليون يوصفون بميلهم الى
الاتحاد مع روسيا لم يحصل الاقليم على اي
اعتراف دولي باستقلاله ويوجد فيه 1500
جنديا روسي تقول موسكو انهم لحفظ السلام
وكانوا ارسلوا بموجب اتفاق بين روسيا
ومولدوفا عام
1992 وفقا لوسائل اعلام الروسيه كما يعتمد
الاقليم على موارد الروسيه تقدم له
بالمجان مثل الغاز يضم الاقليم بسكانه
الذين يقاربون نحو 470
الفارقيات مختلفه روسيه واوكرانيه
ومولدوفيه بنسب مختلفه
[موسيقى]
في تونس اتهمت حركه النهضه ما سمتها سلطه
الانقلاب بالزجي بالقضاء والمؤسسات
الامنيه في السياسه جاء ذلك بعد استدعاء
جديد لرئيس الحركه راشد الغنوشي
للاستجوابه في حين اعلن الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل انه سيدعو لتعبئه شعبيه في
مواجهه السلطه وسيدعو لمظاهرات حاشده مطلع
الشهر القادم
لا يكاد يمر يوم في تونس دون حاله صدام
جديده بين السلطه وخصومها في ظل غياب اي
بوادر على امكانيه حصول انحسار لحاله
التازم السياسي في البلاد احدث التطورات
اعلان حركه النهضه استدعاء الشرطه لزعيمها
رئيس مجلس نواب المنحل راشد الغنوشي
لاستجوابه في اطار تحقيق لم تكشف اسبابه
الحركه لم تكتفي بوصف القضيه بانها مفبركه
وبانها جاءت وفق الدعوه وهي رفعها شخص
مجهول بل اتهمت من وصفتها بسلطه الانقلاب
بانها زجت بالقضاء والمؤسسات الامنيه في
السياسه وسبق ان خضع الغنوشي لتحقيق عده
مرات العام الماضي في قضايا مثل جمعيه
نماء والتمويل غير المشروع والتسفير لبؤر
التوتر والاساءه للجهات الامنيه لكنه لم
يصدر اي قرار قضائي باحتجازه
بيد ان السياق الاستدعاء هذه المره ياتي
وسط موجه غير مسبوقه من الاعتقالات لم
يسبق ان شهدتها تونس منذ 2011 شملات
شخصيات سياسيه ونقابيه وقضائيه القاسم
المشترك بينها انتقاد رئيس قيس سعيد
واضافه للغنوشي اكد الناشط السياسي
والامين العام السابق لحزب التيار
الديمقراطي غازي الشواشي انه استدعي
للتحقيق من اجل قضيه جديده رفعتها ضده
وزيره العدل بتهمه الترويج لاخبار زائفه
بتزكيه من رئيس السلطه القائمه على حد
تعبيره وكان الرئيس قيس سعيد قد اتهمى بعض
من اعتقلوا في الايام الماضيه بالتامر على
امن الدوله وحملهم المسؤوليه عن ازمات نقص
السلع وارتفاع الاسعار
بموازاه كل ذلك تتصاعد حده التجاذبات بين
الرئيس والاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل كبرى
المؤسسات النقابيه والعماليه في البلاد
الاتحاد امتنع عليه اشهر طويله عن توجيه
انتقادات مباشره للرئيس سعيد فان الفجوه
بين الطرفين اخذت بالاتساع لاحقا بعد
اتهام الاتحاد للرئيس بتجاهل دعواته
المتكرره لاطلاق حوار وطني شامل ثم
انتقادي معتبره اعتداءات على الحقوق
النقابيه والحريات وصولا الى بدء سلسله من
الاحتجاجات في عدد من المدن التونسيه يقول
الاتحاد انها ستتواصل وتتوسع كما اعلن
المتحدث باسمه سامي الطاهري بان الاتحاد
سيضطر الى تفعيل مبادره الحوار مع الاحزاب
السياسيه اذا رفضها الرئيس معتبرا انه هو
دوائر الحكم من حوله لا يريدون حوارا
وطنيا بل حكم الفرد الواحد
[موسيقى]
التوتر بين الصين والولايات المتحده لا
يتعلق فقط بقضايا مثل حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وازمه تايوان والمنافسه التجاريه
بل يصل ايضا الى الفضاء الصين تشكل اكبر
تهديد في الفضاء بسبب سباق التسلح المضطرد
هذا ما قاله الجنرال برادلي تشانس
ساتلزمان قائد عمليات الفضاء في سلاح الجو
الامريكي السباق الى التسلح في الفضاء ليس
بجديد فابتداء من عام 85 استخدمت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه صاروخا لتدمير قمر صناعي
امريكي في عمليه تجريبيه ومنذ ذلك الحين
اظهروا منافسون الولايات المتحده انهم
يملكون القدرات نفسها فقد اقدمت الصين على
ذلك في عام 2007 والهند عام 2019 في نهايه
عام 2021 دمرت روسيا احد اقمارها
الاصطناعيه بواسطه صاروخ من الارض واعتبر
ذلك استعراضا للقوه راى فيه الامين العام
لحلف شمال الاطلسي يانسيستور سلوكا غير
مسؤول ولم تعد الاقمار الاصطناعيه التي
يمكن تجهيزها بقنابل عفوا ولا المركبات
الفضائيه التي دخلت على الخط بدورها ضربا
من دروب الخيال العلمي
معركه الفضاء الخارجي تطورت وانتقلت من
فكره تدمير الاقمار الاصطناعيه بواسطه
صواريخ او اقمار اصطناعيه انتحاريه الى
توفير الوسائل لالحاق اضرار بها مع اسلحه
ليزر او موجات صغيره قويه جدا ولكن ماذا
عن صراعات الحاضر قائد عمليات الفضاء في
سلاح الجو الامريكي قال على هامش مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن ان النزاع في اوكرانيا ذكر
كذلك باهميه الفضاء الكبيره في حروب اليوم
وحروب الغد ايضا فالفضاء مهم في المعارك
الحديثه يمكن المهاجمه من الفضاء
عفوا من دون التوجه اليه عبر شبكات
سيبرانيه ووسائط اخرى يقول الضابط
الامريكي رفيع المستوى النشاط العسكري
المفرط الذي يرافقه انتشار تجاري مضطرد
ايضا يطرح مشكله الاضرار الجانبيه والحطام
المدمر وعلى نطاق اوسع يطرح مساله وضع
مدونه سلوك عالميه في هذا المجال طيب ماذا
عنا المستقبل الفضاء سيشهد زحمه كبرى لذا
ثمت حاجه الى قواعد ترسيها معاهدات دوليه
جديده اذا ان الاتفاقات الحاليه لم تعد
تلبي متطلبات التطور التكنولوجي بحسب
الخبراء ينضم الينا من لوس انجلوس الدكتور
عصام حجي عالمي الفضاء دكتور لماذا يجب ان
نقلق من هذه المنافسه بين الدول الكبرى في
الفضاء
في شيء مهم ان المنافسه دي مش جديده
المنافسه دي بقى لها دلوقتي عقود من
الزمان البعض يتخيل ان مشروع الفضاء
الصيني هو وليد لحظات ظهور المنطاد في
السماء الولايات المتحده ولكن مشروع
الفضاء الصيني مشروع متقدم
وموجود منذ مجموعه من العقود يعني من فتره
الخمسينات ببدايه بالصواريخ الباليستيه
مرورا برواد الفضاء مرورا ان الصين اليوم
لها مئات الاقمار
الصناعيه و15 مركز للتحكم في هذه
الاقمار واربعه منصات لاطلاق للفضاء
فالصين اليوم هي احد اهم اللاعبين في مجال
صناعه الفضاء وعلوم الفضاء واكتشاف الفضاء
بشكل عام ما يجب ان يخيف او الختم او يخيف
يعني ما يوقفني انا شخصيا هو انه تسليح
الفضاء معنى وتحطيم الاقمار صناعيه او
اطلاقها بشكل عشوائي سيهدد من الاقمار من
وجود الاقمار الصناعيه السلميه التي تقوم
بدراسات التغير المناخي والحفاظ على كوكب
الارض وسوف تهدد بهذه العشوائيه اقدر اقول
في التعامل مع الاقمار الصناعيه وتدمير
الاقمار الصناعيه في في بعض الحالات لان
الشظايا التي ستنتج عن عمليه التدمير
الغير محكم سد سيكون لها تاثير على
الاقمار الصناعيه المدنيه بشكل عام ما
الذي تعنيه بتسليح القضاء دكتور الفضاء
عفوا دكتور
مبدا تسليح الفضاء اللي هو عمليه التخلص
من اقمار الصناعيه التي تجمع معلومات غير
مستحبه
لدوله ما والبعض يتخيل هذه المعلومات اللي
فقط معسكريه والاستخباراتيه ولكن هل سنرى
في المستقبل ما المجموعات التي التي
مضاده للدراسات التغير المناخي تقوم
بالتعاون مع مجموعه من الدول لتدمير مثل
اقمار التي تقوم التغلب الناخي كل هذا
اصبح مفتوح في حاله في حاله
الاستباحه تدمير الاقمار الصناعيه بشكل
عام بدون تشاور وبدون تقنين لهذه العمليه
ولكن اليس هناك جوانب ايجابيه لتصليح
الفضاء كما تفضلت يعني نحن تابعنا بعض
الافلام نيازك كبيره تصطدم بالارض
جهامات ترسل صاروخا او او مركبه لتفجير
هذا النيزك او هذا الجسم هل هناك جوانب
ايجابيه
هذا ليس تسليح للفضاء ولكن هذا التعامل مع
المخاطر الطبيعيه نحن بالتاكيد نحتاج
لحمايه الكوكب الذي نعيش فيه من مخاطر
ارتطام بالنيازك وعمليه الدفاع عن الارض
من التضام النيازك تتدمر انسان المركبه
مثل مركبه التي قامت بالالتحام بمذنب
بالاصدام بمذنب بدون موجود بدون وجود اي
ماده متفجره على هذه المركبه هو فقط انها
بتنزل على هذا بتعمل عمليه ارتطام بتبعد
هذا المذنب في حاله كوكب في حاله وجود احد
المذنبات الذي يهدد كوكب لذي نعيش عليه في
اخر شيء نتمنى نقوم به هو ارسال صاروخ
للتفتيت هذا المذنب لانه ستحول من جسم
واحد الى الالاف الاجسام التي ستلحق
الدمار بشكل اكبر بكوكب الذي نعيش فيه هل
هناك حاجه لقواعد
لارساء مفهوم خاص بالفضاء في ظل هذا
التنافس الفضائي دكتور
بالتاكيد نحتاج لقواعد هامه ونحتاج انه
استخدام الفضاء يكون للاغراض السلميه
وخلافا على كل الاسلحه اذا كان استخدام
الفضاء سيصبح اكثر بهذا الشكل للاستخدامات
العسكريه فيجب ان نعلم ان الدرع الذي
يقي الكوكب الذي نعيش فيه من المخاطر
الخارجيه اصبح مهدد بهذه السلوكيات بشكل
عام
سريعا دكتور ما هي طبيعه الصواريخ القادره
ان تنطلق من الارض لتفجر قمرا صناعيا مثلا
هذا نظام معقد يعني هنا هي الصواريخ
الباليستيه الطويله المدى ولكن نحتاج هنا
لمعرفه دقيقه باماكن وجود هذه الاقمار
الصناعيه ويوجد ايضا استخدام عمليه
استخدام الليزر الموجود على
الارضيه لابطال مفعول اجهزه التصوير على
الاقمار الصناعيه هناك مجموعه من الحزم
التي موجوده لابطال مفعول الاقمار
الصناعيه التي تقوم بالتجسس وهذا موجود
منذ عام 2000 وليس بالجديد ابدا علم
الفضاء في لوس انجلوس الدكتور عصام حجي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
عندما يصبح العراء مكسبا واللجوء اليه
ملحن هذا ما يحدث في جنوب تركيا وشمال
غربي سوريا الخيام باتت من الكماليات بل
هي الكماليات على الاقل لا يخشى انهيارها
وما قد يصيبها من ضرر لا يبعث على قلق
كبير تصوروا كيف كان الانسان يعيش قبل
اسبوعين امنا في في معافى في بدنه واليوم
ملايين الناس في الطرقات